So, es war echt recht früh heute.
Leute, 8.42 Uhr, so früh sind wir nie.
Packweight.
Also, dieses Taskleisten einblenden, im Fullscreen, wenn ich das Display wechsle bzw.
das Fenster den Fokus verliert, ist schon nervig.
Ich meine, das Problem ist unter Windows 10 nicht da und im Firefox auch nicht.
Das heißt, es muss irgendwas mit Chrome zu tun haben.
Chrome Fullscreen Taskbar Showing.
Guck mal da, da steht doch was.
Taskbar, why is Taskbar Showing in Fullscreen Chrome?
On the left, hide the Taskbar in desktop, ne, das ist doch blödsinnig.
Irgendwelche Windows-Settings will ich ja nicht haben.
Das ist ja, das ist ja blödsinnig, das ist ja eine Chrome-Sache.
Taskbar Nord...
Boah, Alter, meine Augen.
Guck mal, da gibt es tatsächlich einen Bug dazu.
Fullscreen, ja, Fullscreen-Video does not fully maximise in Chrome, ja, nicht nur in
Chrome 86, in Chrome 101 immer noch.
Joktern scheint kein.
Ja, mein Leute, das ist echt früh, ich merk's, aber hat ja keinen Sinn.
Warum soll ich noch 20 Minuten hier sinnlos rauf besetzen?
Ich kann auch jetzt schon einfach Streamer machen.
Okay, ja, Fullscreen.
Nicht Fullscreen, sobald das Fenster, seht ihr, sobald das Fenster Fokus verliert, brennt
sich die Kackleiste ein.
Firefox ist es nicht.
Vielleicht wird es echt Zeit, komplett für Streaming-Sachen auf Firefox einfach umzusteigen.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als könntest du mit Firefox nicht auch alles machen, ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum hab ich eigentlich Chromium, Chrome, Firefox und, ähm, Vivaldi
und, ich glaub, das war's.
Warum hab ich eigentlich 150 Browser installiert?
Theoretisch reicht eigentlich Firefox für die ganzen Sachen hier aus.
Ich mein, ich weiß, warum ich, also warum ich installiert hab, weiß ich, ich mach's
auf meinem anderen Account so, Chrome verwende ich rein für die Arbeit, für Homeoffice und
irgendwelche Remount-Sachen, Chromium verwende ich zum privaten Surfen und Firefox verwende
ich für YouTube und alles, was damit zusammenhängt.
So, das heißt, jetzt wäre es eigentlich am sinnvollsten, einfach hier immer Firefox
für alles zu verwenden, weil der hat dieses doofe Problem nicht.
Das Blöde ist bloß, ich müsste meine Tabs konvertieren.
Gibt es einen, gibt es einen, Chrome Tabs to Firefox Tabs?
Ich mein, ich könnte einfach alle Tabs bookmarken und in Firefox wieder aufmachen, ja, das geht
nicht, ja.
Da kann ich ihn bestimmt, bestimmt konvertieren, Chrome Bookmarks to Firefox, Chrome Bookmarks
to Firefox, gibt's doch bestimmt, jaja, gibt es.
Da könnte ich nämlich einfach alle meine Tabs, also wer diesen Trick nicht kennt, man
kann, guck mal, ich will jetzt das hier bookmarken, ja, man kann das hier alles markieren und
dann sagt man bookmark all Tabs und dann kann man einen Ordner machen mit allen Tabs drinnen
und die könnte ich dann importieren in Firefox.
Ich glaube heute leben wir nochmal mit Chrome, auch wenn das wirklich nervig ist, dass sich
die Taskleiste laufend einblendet.
Zumal es nur in Windows 11 ist, also das ist irgendwas, was mit den Settings, also mit
dem internen Handling, welches Fenster on top ist, also sprich, ist die Taskleiste dann
immer on top, allerdings nur wenn es keinen Fokus hat oder ihr müsst das Fenster, was
on top ist, auf Fokus haben, da hat sich wahrscheinlich was in Windows 11 geändert.
Anders kann man sich das...
Und sonst habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst?
Lass mal überlegen, was waren die Wochen, eigentlich nix großartiges.
Es gab diese Web-Chasen-Lücke, wer das Mittel gekriegt hat, da kann ich euch was lustiges
zu erzählen.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es teilweise so richtig blinden Aktionismus, ob wahr?
Ist das Upgrade auf Windows 11 schon zu empfehlen?
Ne, nur wenn es sinnvoll ist, also wenn man irgendwas unter Windows 10 braucht, was es
unter Windows 11 nicht gibt.
Echt, haben die da was geändert?
Also der Grund, warum ich auf Windows 11 bin, ist ganz einfach, weil ich 32 Logical Processors
habe, aufgeteilt in High Performance Cores und Efficiency Cores und das kann Windows
10 nicht richtig handeln.
Kann nur der Windows 11 Scheduler oder Linux, das funktioniert natürlich auch.
Und deswegen habe ich Windows 11, das ist der einzige Grund, ansonsten packt mich Windows
11 eigentlich regelmäßig jeden Tag ab.
Also was mir ohne Scheiß, was mir mit Abschonung am meisten auf dem Keks geht, ist das hier,
dass ich das Taskswitchen hier drüber machen muss, anstatt einfach hier, ich meine, guck
mal, ich brauche nichts von meiner Taskbar, die ist einfach leer, ich hätte gerne Text
daneben und ich hätte gerne, kann man den Text eigentlich wieder einpletten?
Wenigstens das, geht das vielleicht?
Ne, gell, das ist Legacy Feature, das braucht man nicht.
Das vielleicht ausmachen, dass das hier im Fullscreen funktioniert?
Tja, leider geht das anscheinend nicht.
Das stimmt, das wollten wir uns ja auch mal angucken, dann reacten wir auf die Reaction.
Warum, was, wobei nicht Spoiler, nicht Spoiler, wir gucken uns das nachher an, falls es den
auch gibt, falls es den auch als Wort gibt, dann gucken wir uns das an.
Ich habe es nicht geguckt bis jetzt.
Ich habe bloß mal ganz kurz reingezappt, da war er verwirrt, weil ich so viele ungelesene
E-Mails habe, dann habe ich wieder ausgemacht, habe ich mir gedacht, ich gucke mir das zusammen
mit euch an.
Bin am Überlegen, für die Arbeit in der Studium eine Doppel-Distribution aufzusetzen, also
Windows und Linux.
Ja, das würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen, also gerade technische Sachen oder sag mal
generell alles, was nicht gut unter Windows, eh gut, das ist jetzt bescheuert, das so rum
zu sagen, es gibt einige Sachen, die funktionieren unter Linux besser, wenn du was programmieren
willst, wenn du irgendwelche Netzwerksachen machen musst, was basteln, das funktioniert
unter Linux, aber wenn du ein Terminal brauchst, ordentliche Terminal, Umgebung, Tools, sonst
was, es ist vieles unter Linux deutlich angenehmer, aber trotzdem, ich brauche gerade für Gaming,
YouTube-Videos, Streaming und sowas immer noch mein Windows.
Man spricht dagegen, dass du keine, dass du kein Dual-Boot machst, sondern man spricht
dagegen, das so zu machen wie ich, dass du, also wenn du einen halbwegs modernen, relativ
schnellen Rechner hast, man spricht dagegen, remind me later, dass du einfach Linux auf
den zweiten Desktop aufmachst, ich meine Linux in der VM ist wirklich schnell genug,
sofern du nicht irgendwelche Hardware decodete Videos schauen willst, wobei du das auch unter
Windows machen kannst, und sofern du nicht irgendwelche 3D Sachen benutzen möchtest.
Der Rest ist wirklich kaum zu unterscheiden von einem direkt installierten System, ich
meine man spricht dagegen, guck mal, du hast hier Windows auf dem ersten Desktop, also
die Desktops kannst du hier unter Windows 11 über dieses komische Nichts sagen, der
Icon hier unten einstellen, und dann kannst du einfach Shortcut machen und Desktop switchen,
dann hast du hier Linux auf dem zweiten Desktop im Fullscreen, von der Performance her, wie
gesagt, solang es nicht 3D ist und solang es nicht Video Decoding ist, kaum zu unterscheiden
von einem richtigen Desktop Installation, und hier kannst du ihn nur näher switchen,
wie du willst, also so mache ich das.
So verwende ich, also ich habe hier immer eine VM auf mit Linux auf dem zweiten Desktop
und hier mein Windows Zeug, das benutze ich jeden Tag so, und ich würde sagen je nachdem
was ich mache verbringe ich so 50-50, also alles was irgendwie mit Technik zu tun hat
mache ich, oder mit IT zu tun hat mache ich unter Linux, und wenn ich dann halt ein paar
Stunden Zeug spiele, dann mache ich das unter Windows, dann so einfach.
Welche VM und welches Linux, ein Arch Linux By the Way natürlich, was denn sonst, gerade
mal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwelche Updates gibt, selbstverständlich Arch Linux, ähm,
das ist I3 als Window Manager, kann ich dir auch empfehlen für VMs, einfach weil es
dort nichts gibt, da gibt es keine Animationen, keine Überblendung oder sonstige nervigen
Sachen, läuft besonders gut in VMs, kannst aber auch XFCE oder irgendwas benutzen, ich
würde bloß abraten von Gnome, weil das mittlerweile irgendwie auch GPU Acceleration und Gedönswill
für die Oberfläche.
Bis zum gewissen Maße geht es in der VM, aber es nicht, das ist vor allem bei Workstation,
vor allem bei Workstation, vor allem bei Workstation kannst du entweder kaufen oder benutzt den
Player, der kostet nichts, übrigens, glaube Windows, hat wieder, was soll das Scheiß
Windows machen, immer diese Rumgestelle, Alter, man findet es auch nicht, ja, wie gesagt,
das ist vor allem bei Workstation, du kannst auch Virtual Box nehmen, aber ich persönlich
finde vor allem bei Workstation angenehmer als Virtual Box, ja gut, aber das muss ja
nicht Windows 11 sein, das könnte ja Windows 10 genauso gut machen, es ist tatsächlich,
ich finde auch, man erkennt schon ein bisschen, gerade auch diese neue Taskleiste, ja, das
sieht, also, wie kann man diesen Crap hier eigentlich, ich will diesen Scheiß nicht
haben, Search Settings, ne, ist das jetzt weg, ok, gut, will dieses komische automatische
eingeb... kann man das nicht wegmachen, dass das Webinhalte einblendet, geht anscheinend
nicht, ne, Webinhalte muss man, muss man haben, ob man die jetzt will oder nicht, kann man
das ausschalten, ich will nicht, dass meine Taskleiste das Internet durchsucht, und wenn
ich nach Cackle suche, oder CacWee suche, was war das, Encryption, was, Key Encryption,
Key Label, Cackle 2, ja, warum nicht, das war useless, das ist einfach neu, kann ich
in der VM auch auf alle Daten zugreifen, das kommt darauf an, wie du das einstellst, also
ich persönlich finde es sogar ganz gut, wenn VMs und Windows ein bisschen, also kannst
du machen, ja, ich finde es ganz gut, wenn VM und Windows ein bisschen getrennt sind,
was du natürlich jederzeit machen kannst, ist Track und Drop, also du kannst zum Beispiel
sagen, hier, ich will jetzt mein Windows Background hier in die VM Track und Dropen, und du kannst
auch Track und Dropen von der VM in Windows rein, das funktioniert auch, wenn du wirklich
was austauschen willst, also ich kann dir zeigen, dass das funktioniert, ja, guck, und
du kannst sagen, hier, ich will jetzt Helper CS, will ich unbedingt in Windows haben, zack,
ah, das funktioniert mit der neuen Taskleiste nicht, nice, ggeats, alter Windows ist so
verkackt mittlerweile, einfach das Wahnsinn, guck mal, das haben die kaputt gemacht, guckt
euch das mal an, broken as fuck, das ist auch was, was kaputt ist mit Windows 11, das Raustrack
und Dropen aus der VM, ach, hier hin gehts, oh, das ist so schlecht, man, es ist so schlecht
Windows 11 an vielen Stellen, die haben auch was im Track und Drop geändert, ok, Track
und Drop auf Desktop geht, weil halt Track und Drop auf Desktop wohl noch immer das
alte Track und Drop verwenden, aber das neue Track und Drop in, ach, Moment, das ist weil
ich im falschen Explorer Fenster bin, in Documents gehts wahrscheinlich, oder? Ja, in Documents
gehts, ok, also du kannst Raustrack und Dropen aus der VM, und was du machen kannst ist,
also wenn du sagst, hey, ich brauch ganz dringend unbedingt alle Ordner, du kannst in die Settings
gehen, das mach ich aber so gut wie nie, und du kannst bei, wo ist denn das überhaupt,
hier, shared folders, kannst du theoretisch dein komplettes C-Laufwerk reinhängen in
die VM, wenn du das wirklich haben willst, ich will das nicht, das kannst du machen,
wenn du das haben willst, ich Track und Drop ab und zu mal was hin und her, von Windows
auf Linux und von Linux auf Windows, das wars aber eigentlich, ansonsten hab ich nicht so
viel Datenaustausch zwischen der Linux VM und Windows, weil es ist halt relativ getrennt,
ich mach eh allen Technikgrabs unter Linux in der VM und Gaming Sachen unter, also es
passiert ganz selten, dass ich mal was Track und Dropen muss, ja, so siehts aus, No Niveau,
Englische für den Sub, ja, stimmt, ich wollte doch eben irgendwas erzählen, chat bringt
mich mal, erinnert mich mal, was wollte ich erzählen, ich hab irgendwas erzählt bei uns,
Alter, Boomer, Boomer Gehirn, naja, ich weiß wieder, stimmt, es ging ja darum, was heute,
was die Woche passiert ist, es war folgendes, vielleicht nehm ich heute was auf, vielleicht
nehm ich, vielleicht nehm ich heute was auf, was meint ihr, was ich zuerst aufnehmen soll,
also von Videos, wo es tatsächlich um die Arbeit geht, ich hab ja noch ein paar andere
Sachen, soll ich zuerst aufnehmen, so Gehaltsentwicklung oder soll ich zuerst aufnehmen, mein Lebenslauf,
Bewerbung und Skill-Liste, Lebenslauf und was war es noch, achso, das Kündigungsschreiben,
das wollten tatsächlich auch einige sehen und ich mir denke, ey, das ist eine 0815 Kündigung
aus dem Internet, also ich irgendwie zwei Sätze kopiert aus zwei Vorlagen und abgegeben.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich erzählen wollte und zwar, oh, ich muss mich mal kurz
hinstellen Leute, das schlafe ich gleich ein, das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, so, also, was
wollte ich denn erzählen, ich könnte jetzt eigentlich auch meinen Schreibtisch hochfahren,
weil ich hab ja schon lange einen hinverstellbaren Schreibtisch, aber ich bin so faul, dass mein
Schreibtisch quasi, dass da nichts runterhängt und sonst was, da hängen irgendwie Kabel runter
und dann muss ich immer dreimal gucken, bevor ich ihn hochfahre, dass das alles funktioniert,
ohne dass was runterfällt und deswegen fahre ich den eigentlich nie hoch, obwohl ich schon
seit Jahren einen hinverstellbaren Schreibtisch hab, also Neujahrs, ich hab keine Neujahrsziele,
abnehmen, es ist mehr oder weniger gleich, es ist ein paar Gramm mehr geworden über
Weihnachten wieder, aber jetzt ist es wieder auch ein bisschen runter, also es ist noch
nicht unter, es hat nicht ganz geklappt, das tiefste was ich hatte war 91,4 glaube ich,
ich wollte ja unter 90, aber guck mal, irgendwann, also ich werde das jetzt nicht darauf hinarbeiten
und quasi sagen, hey, ich esse jetzt nichts mehr oder so, ich mach das in dem Tempo weiter,
wie ich es das letzte Jahr über auch gemacht hab, weil das hat ja immerhin für so 17 Kilo
irgendwie in dem Dreh gereicht und deswegen werde ich es da nicht übertreiben, ja genau,
also was ich jetzt erzählen wollte ist folgendes, bevor wir uns dann gleich ein paar Sachen angucken,
also was ich erzählen wollte ist folgendes, es ist teilweise, es ist teilweise wirklich
bei uns auf der, also da wo ich gerade arbeite, ist irgendwie ein bisschen so blinder Aktionismus,
es gab doch, es gab diese Woche eine Lücke in einer Javascript Library, wer hätte das
gedacht und zwar in Jason Web Token, können wir uns gerade mal zusammen angucken, genau
und irgendein Manager bei uns, ich muss das im Chromium aufmachen, weil ich da den Dark
Reader am Start hab und irgendein Manager bei uns hat das gelesen und hat gemeint, ooooh,
ganz furchtbar, ich mein immerhin, immerhin hat er das, ein Manager der sowas liest, das
weiß ich ja schon mal was, hat ein bisschen die falschen Schlüsse draus gezogen, so
dachte ich immer, ooooh, eine ganz ganz schlimme Javascript, nee der wusste nicht mal Javascript,
eine ganz ganz schlimme Lücke und dann hat er den Auftrag erteilt, bitte unsere Software
überprüfen, ob die davon betroffen ist, das ist ja vom Prinzip her genau sein Job, da
kann ich ja nichts dagegen sagen, das Problem war wieder nur, wie sie das beauftragt haben
und was die Leute dann daraus gemacht haben, also normalerweise das erste was man machen
sollte, meiner Ansicht nach, ihr könnt mir mal in den Chat schreiben wie ihr das seht,
aber meiner Ansicht nach das erste wenn man irgendwie sowas liest, ist nicht unbedingt
den heise Artikel sich durchzulesen, ja, siehste, genau, ach mittlerweile haben sie es geupdated,
mittlerweile haben sie es geupdated zwei Tage danach, ja, ja, das ist nämlich genau
sowas ähnliches was ich auch gesagt habe, also, man kann sich zwar den heise Artikel
durchlesen aber der heise Artikel war wirklich schlecht, was Lieferkettenangriffe das ergibt
in dem Sinn auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn so wirklich, ja, wichtig ist man muss sich
mal den original Blogpost durchlesen, das ist das was ich bei allen Sicherheitslücken
immer empfehlen kann, ich hoffe das ist noch im original, ja, sich mal die original Meldung
durchzulesen, weil ich habe den Eindruck, dass viele Newsseiten oftmals nicht so genau
checken oder keine Zeit haben um was es da geht, so und das erste was ich gemacht habe
ist ich habe mir mal den Blogpost durchgelesen und das klingt zwar alles relativ, also relativ
problematisch, aber wenn man dann mal runterscrollt und sich das durchliest, wird man irgendwann
feststellen, wenn man dann zu dem Punkt kommt, wie kann diese Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt
werden, bei diesem ganz viel bla bla, wie kann die Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt werden,
stellt man fest, damit das funktioniert, muss in diese Variable secret or public key, secret
or public key, hier ist es, also secret or public key wird hier an die Verify Funktion
übergeben, das ist der eigentliche Knackpunkt, so und wenn der zweite Parameter, wenn das
ein manipuliertes JavaScript Objekt ist, dann wird das ausgeführt, warum, weil das einfach
toString aufruft und wenn du jetzt ein JavaScript Objekt anlegst und darin toString überschreibst,
also wenn du schaffst ein JavaScript Objekt da rein zu bekommen, mit überschriebener toString
Methode, dann wird das ausgeführt, das ist aber gar nicht mal so einfach, ich würde
mal behaupten, das ist nahezu unmöglich, wenn du nicht Zugriff hast auf den Server selbst
oder wenn du nicht Zugriff hast auf die Quelle, aus der secret or public key ausgelesen wird,
meistens dürfte das vom Filesystem kommen und dann muss das auch noch beim Auslesen
irgendwie gepasst werden als JavaScript Objekt, also das ist eigentlich, das ist das, was
ich am Freitag auch gesagt habe, eigentlich ist das überhaupt nicht so krass, wie das
sich am Anfang anhört, also das auszunutzen ist Remote, auch wenn da irgendwie was dasteht,
was das Remote ausnutzen kann, das ist eigentlich nicht möglich, das Remote auszunutzen, weil
es ist ja nicht so, als würde der Client irgendwie diese Sache hier schicken, sondern
das ist rein auf den Server und der Server fragt dann im Hintergrund das vielleicht von
irgendwo ab oder liest es aus dem File, also entweder brauchst du Server Access oder Zugriff
auf den Key Vault, wo auch immer das herkommt und dann muss es irgendwie noch zum JavaScript
Objekt mit überschriebener toString Methode werden, das passiert nicht einfach mal zufällig
so, kann es eigentlich knicken, also wie gesagt, ich fand es überhaupt gar nicht weiter wild,
also es wäre aus meiner Sicht noch nicht mal nötig gewesen, dass man unsere, gibt
es ja nicht so viele, aber es gibt doch ein paar Node-Anwendungen oder ein paar JavaScript-Anwendungen,
dass man die jetzt instant irgendwie patcht oder da irgendwie ein extra Patch-Fenster macht
oder so, da wäre schlicht und greifend einfach gar nichts passiert bei dieser Lücke, nichts.
So, habe ich mir das durchgelesen und es hat natürlich schon mal so, es hat ja 20-30 Minuten
gedauert, bis ich das gelesen habe, bis ich alles verstanden habe, dann habe ich so eine
kleine Einschätzung gepostet bei uns im Teams und in der Zwischenzeit sind die Leute schon
wieder komplett panisch rumgerannt, weil irgendein Manager gesagt hat, oha hier bitte überprüfen
und das erste, was daraus hervorgeht ist, dass das Backend-Anwendungen sind, die betroffen
sind, also Node.js, vielleicht noch Deno, keine Ahnung, oder Bann oder was auch immer,
also Backend-Anwendungen, die diese Sache verwenden, das ist alles, also es müssen Node.js-Anwendungen
sein, es müssen zumindest JavaScript-Backend-Anwendungen sein, dass das davon betroffen ist.
Es reicht nicht, wenn du einfach mal in dein Package Jason guckst und feststellst, aha,
diese Anwendung hat eine Abhängigkeit da drauf, wenn es keine Backend-Node.js-Anwendung
ist, also mal angenommen, du hast in Vue.js Frontend und irgendwas bringt über 5 Ecken,
das als Abhängigkeit mit, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass es dich klein-seitig eh nicht juckt an der Stelle, weil was willst
du für einen Code einschleusen, soll der Client in sich selbst Code einschleusen oder was,
also das ist ja schon mal blödsinnig, also da ist es selbst egal und was haben sie gemacht,
anstatt mal diesen Blogpost zu lesen und geistig zu verarbeiten, habe ich dann mal ins Ticket
geguckt und ich konnte meinen Augen nicht trauen, was da in unserem Ticket drin stand,
in unserem Ticket stand drinne, Alert-Manager nicht betroffen, Alert-Manager, Alert-Manager
ist in Go programmiert, ist eine Go-Software als Notification-Dings-Aufsatz für Prometheus,
Alert-Manager und da stand ganz viel Software in Go drinne, nicht betroffen, nicht betroffen,
da denke ich mir, alter Leute, hat man euch ins Hirn geschissen oder was, das erste Blick,
erster Satz, weißt du, das ist Go-Software ist nicht betroffen, also da habe ich mir
wieder gedacht, mein Gott sei Dank alle bescheuert oder was, das ist doch, das ist der, das erste,
den ersten fucking Satz, wenn du dir das Modul anguckst, dass es ein JavaScript Node.js Modul
ist, die Aussage ist wahr, ja, Cobol-Software auf Mainframe ist auch nicht besonders, einmal
zu viel Alarm schlagen, das Alarm schlagen ist doch gar nicht das Problem, das Problem
ist, dass die Leute daraufhin losrennen und Sachen kontrollieren, ohne sich mal mit dem
eigentlichen Problem zu beschäftigen, du kannst nicht einfach sinnlos irgendwas kontrollieren,
willst du jetzt jegliche Software kontrollieren, ob die JSON Web-Talks verwendet, nein, du
willst kontrollieren, ob irgendeine Backend-Software von dir, also wahrscheinlich zu 99% Node.js
Software, diese JavaScript Library verwendet, who cares irgendwelche Node, who cares irgendwelche
Go-Software, irgendwelche Java-Software oder sonst was, vollkommen egal und warum passiert
sowas, weil viel zu sehr darauf geguckt wird, dass jeder möglichst schnell auf das Ticket
in seinem Bereich eine wie auch immer geartete Reaktion postet, es ist egal, ob das was sinnvoll
ist oder nicht sinnvoll ist, darauf räuft es dann heraus, dass die Leute irgendwelche
Go-Software überprüfen, also es ist unglaublich bescheuert gewesen, so, dann habe ich gesehen,
dass manche Leute gepostet haben, oh, diese Software ist betroffen und am Ende war es
wirklich irgendwelche Webfrontend-Geschichten, die das über drei Ecken mitgebracht haben
als Dependencies und wisst ihr was mich bei sowas ja auch immer richtig triggert, ich
habe das ja in den Teams-Channel dazu, wir haben ja so einen Teams-Channel für solche
Sachen, ich habe das in den Teams-Channel geschrieben, so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde,
nachdem der erste Post gekommen ist, einfach weil ich das lesen musste, verarbeiten musste,
ich habe reingeschrieben, Leute, also ich habe mir das mal durchgelesen im Detail, das
betrifft uns zwar, aber nur in Node.js Backends, also es ist überhaupt kein Grund, also es
ist überhaupt nicht eilig da jetzt, es schadet nichts das Zeug zu patchen, ja, aber es ist
überhaupt nicht eilig, es wird überhaupt nichts passieren, aus diesen und diesen Gründen,
du kannst das überhaupt nicht ausführen, es sei denn eventuell hat jemand Zugriff auf
unseren Key Vault, dann haben wir eh andere Probleme und außerdem dann muss immer noch
als JavaScript-Objekt gepasst werden, was auch nicht passiert, so, habe ich reingeschrieben,
glaube es hat keine Sorge lesen, aber alle anderen Posts, Alert-Manager nicht betroffen,
haben irgendwie fünf Daumen hoch gekriegt, Alert-Manager nicht betroffen, ja, like, like,
ja, super, like, haha, aber mal eine ordentliche Analyse so nach dem Motto, guck mal, diese
Meldung sagt eigentlich das und das aus keine Sau interessiert, die haben das einfach überlesen
und ihren Scheiß weiter kontrolliert, da wurden dann Java-Software kontrolliert, Go-Software
kontrolliert, JavaScript Frontends kontrolliert, ob die Scheiße nicht verknüpft ist, ey,
es ist teilweise denke ich mir, alter, die sind einfach alle so blöde, naja, ups, das
wollte ich jetzt gar nicht anmachen, das stimmt, das stimmt, ja bin ich ja, bin ich ja, das
ist aber woanders auch nicht besser, das ist so ein Ding, das hast du überall, schau dir
mal, easy Windows-Switcher an, du kannst dann wie unter Linux Alt plus Hütchen, ich weiß
übrigens immer noch nicht, wie dieses komische Zeichen heißt, das ist nicht Zirkumflex, das
ist irgendwas anderes, ich sag immer Hütchen, das heißt ja offiziell gar nicht Hütchen,
aber zum Fenster wechseln kann ich auch Alt abdrücken, oder? Oder meinst du quasi, dass
ich hier die Sachen durchschalten kann, dass ich dann sagen kann, quasi Windows-Taste eins
ist das, das geht doch jetzt auch schon, oder? Easy, das muss ich hier aufmachen, easy Windows-Switcher,
gleich mal her, Reddit, nicht Reddit, Github, Fast Windows-Switcher, gibt das nicht mal,
ist die Windows-Switcher, oder? Das ist keine Open-Source-Software, das ist irgendwelche,
aber vielleicht nicht sowas hierher, ähnlich, Fast Windows-Switcher using Keyboard, easy
Windows-Switcher, nee sowas aus fragwürdiger Quelle installiere ich mir nicht, easy Windows-Switcher
makes switching between Windows as easy as Alt plus Spectics, forget it, hä? So ein
Screenshot wäre ganz nice, oder? Dass man einfach versteht, was es eigentlich macht.
Ok, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es macht, wahrscheinlich auch nichts, was ich brauche. Ich würde die
Software kaufen, ja, hätte ich gar keine Probleme mit, aber ich will nicht Software
von mir auf Windows installieren, von irgendeiner Firma, von irgendeiner Quelle, wo ich keine
Ahnung hab, was es ist, wo es herkommt. Anti-Cheat-Punkt der U will ich auch nicht haben.
Ach, das ist seit Jahren schon kacke, in den Details, zum Übersicht finde ich heiße, ist
echt in Ordnung, aber halt, die Details, die könnten sich, ganz ehrlich, bei diesem Artikel
hier, ja, heiße, ja, bei diesem Artikel hier, ohne Mist, es hätte eigentlich das hier gereicht,
die, die detailliertere Einschätzung, gerade das hier unten und sowas, es ist alles so
ein bisschen weird champ. Sag ich doch. Jetzt hab ich von Anfang gesagt, dass es totaler
Schwachsinn ist, dass das da für Panik gemacht wird, aber ich hätte lieber geguckt, anstatt
oder wild irgendwelche Sachen gemacht, anstatt sich mal mit der Problematik auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja, ganz einfach. Richtig, das ist total sinnlos an der Stelle.
Ich hab hier eine Frage übersehen, wozu ich noch was sagen wollte, aber finde ich jetzt
gerade nicht mehr. Kann ja nicht sein, oder? Chat ist hier alles drin. Servus, schau dich
seit elf Jahren auf YouTube, aber heute erstmal wirklich im Stream nice. Ja, das ist doch schön.
Ich finde es immer cool, wenn die Leute schreiben, dass sie damals irgendwie meine Videos zur
Ausbildung geguckt haben oder sowas und deswegen dann Physi gelernt haben. Das habe ich gar
nicht damit zu wirklich bezwecken wollen damals, aber hat's anscheinend. Also Leute,
falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, sagt Bescheid. Na gut, dann lasst uns doch mal schnell
nochmal in die Github Trends gucken. Achso, was macht denn der Fiat-Cham? Gibt es irgendwelche
Issues? Nein, gibt's nicht. Keine neuen. Lass mal kurz gucken, was trendet. Lass mich raten,
ganz viel AI Zeug wieder. Trending. Alles wild fix. Trending this week. Nano-GPT. WhatsApp-GPT.
Ich habe doch gesagt, die haben eine Menge Machine Learning Zeug, was sonst? Konk. Was?
Okay, die haben zumindest schon mal ein cooles Logo. Sollen Wellen sein, so könnte auch eine
Muschel sein oder so. Better structured concurrency for Go. Blazingly fast written in Go. Geht
eigentlich nicht. Nur in Rust können wir Blazingly fast sein. Go ist teilweise auch
schon ein bisschen hässlich, oder? Ah, das ist, dass man Channels nicht mehr von Hand benutzen
muss. Oder wie, verstehe ich das jetzt? Also sprich, man kann sich dieses ganze, ganze
Channel-Gedöns sparen. Ja, warum nicht? Also Go ist manchmal schon ein bisschen hässlich.
Weil das geht ja hier noch, aber ein bisschen hässlich ist es schon. Alles klar, jetzt
wissen wir auch, dass es das gibt. PyTorch-Reimplementation of GPT. Okay, alles klar. AI, Web-Dev-Vorbeginner,
das ist Proxy, WhatsApp-Proxy, GPT. Twi-Moji. Oh, tatsächlich. Den verwende ich auch, den
Emoji-Fond habe ich immer unter Linux. Twi-Moji, beste. Mag die Twitter-Emoji immer noch nach
wie vor am liebsten. China-Chinesen-Zeug. China-Chinesen-Zeug. Krypto-Zeug. Haben wir
letztes Jahr schon? Letztes Jahr war das auch schon in den Trends. Also vor zwei Wochen.
Jason Crack. Big. Jet-GPT-Chrome-Extension. Naja, wie gesagt, vieler AI-Zeug diesmal ist
nicht so wirklich spannendes Zeug drinnen. Nee, nee, ich spaupe ein Längemittel. Lass
mal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwas Neues, irgendwas Spannendes gibt dafür. Meistens gibt es ja
nichts. OpenAI. Oh, es gibt ein OpenAI-SDK für.NET. BPF. Da machen wir einen großen
Bogen drumherum hier. Spectre-Konsole. Endlich mal was Gutes, was trendet. Spectre-Konsole
ist ein super Library. Da kann man z.B. Tabellen in der Konsole malen und sowas. Also wer mal
ein bisschen fancy-Konsole-Ausgabe machen will, der sollte sich das mal angucken. Da kannst
du z.B. in der Konsole sowas malen. Mach das mal von Hand. Du rastest aus, wenn du sowas
von Hand machen musst. Ja, wenn du sowas von Hand malen musst, drehste durch. Also kann
ich wirklich empfehlen, verwende ich gerne. So. Oh ja. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Wir
sehen das nicht, sondern es ist spannend, dass es getrendet ist. Das können wir uns
jetzt ansehen. Und fertig.
Neun Must-Have-Apps für das Homelab Setup. Ok. Neuer Monitor. Hier ist einfach YouTube
offen. Ok. Das wäre jetzt zu harte Kost für Moins. Neun new AI-Tools that will blow your
mind. Diese Videos mit diesen Titeln klingen immer so, dass du denkst, da kommt jetzt
was richtig Cooles. Und meistens ist es so, ja gut, jetzt haben wir es gesehen, aber benutzen
werde ich trotzdem nicht. Ok, das gucken wir. Neun Must-Have-Apps for a Homelab Setup. Aha,
wir müssen uns das Video gar nicht angucken. Manchmal finde ich dieses Chapter Ding sinnvoll
von YouTube. Wir müssen uns das gar nicht angucken. Wir können einfach gucken, was
die neuen Apps sind und brauchen das Video nicht zu sehen. Übrigens, das haben aber
auch schon Leute auf YouTube gemerkt, dass das keine allzu gute Idee ist, die Chapters
so sinnvoll zu benennen. Deswegen habe ich schon oft gesehen, dass die Leute da hier
sagen, Topic 1, Topic 2, Topic 3, Topic 4 und sowas, dass du gar nicht genau weißt,
was. Ok, also was hat er denn hier? Lass mal kurz gucken. Nextcloud, ja. Vansimus. Proxmox.
Naja. Vansimus. Docker. Das ist doch kein extra Tool fürs Homelab. Das ist ein Standardding
mittlerweile. Portainer. Wenn man auf GUI-Sachen steht, meinetwegen. Photoprism. Die Sachen
sind schon ziemlich, ziemlich random, oder? Photoprism. Ja, ok, das kann bestimmt sinnvoll
sein. Jellyfin. Das kann sicherlich auch sinnvoll sein. Homo Assistant. Das ist sehr sinnvoll,
habe ich auch. Wireguard. Kann sinnvoll sein, wenn man von außen drauf zugreifen will.
Borgbackup. Das ist tatsächlich cool, ob ich auch eine Weile verwendet. Easy, sitze. Schon
haben wir ein 10 Minuten Video komprimiert auf 30 Sekunden. Er sorgt für sichere Straßen.
Das Gehalt als Straßenbaumeister bei der Stadt. Lohnt sich das? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich
hoffe für ihn, dass es sich lohnt, aber wahrscheinlich lohnt es sich unterm Strich nicht. Sowas ist
wahrscheinlich nicht gut bezahlt. Guck mal, die Videos sind immer gut gemacht. Das Video
war echt sinnlos. Warum? Erfährt man, das werden wir jetzt gleich feststellen. Alles
abgesackt. Irgendeiner muss da sein, der das kontrolliert. Ob es Arbeit ist, ob es Geld
verdienen muss, geht alles für die Familie. Was auch richtig so ist. Richtig und wichtig.
Richtig und wichtig, wie ich diese Redewellung hasse, Alter. Hallo, ich bin Thomas Lennart,
36 Jahre alt, Straßenbaumeister bei der Stadt Dortmund. Morgens, so wie andere ihren Kaffee
trinken, so trinke ich meinen Tee. Kein Frühstück. Frühstück gibt es erst auf der Arbeit. Warum
auch nicht? Das mache ich übrigens auch so. Stimmt überhaupt nicht. Habe ich so gemacht,
mache ich mittlerweile nicht mehr. Früher auch so gemacht. Ich habe auf der Arbeit immer
erst gefuttert, sparst da schlicht und ergreifend Zeit und im Zug sitzen kannst du auch ohne
was gegessen zu haben. Aber nachdem ich ja immer ein bisschen später fahre als früher,
esse ich schnell noch was vorher. Ich stehe dann einfach, wenn 7.30 oder 8.30 je nach
dem, wenn der Zug fährt, dann stehe ich halt so auf, dass ich vorher noch schnell was
futtern kann. Das ist angenehmer, da muss ich auch nichts mitnehmen. Oder höchstens
für Mittags was. Also seit ich mir für Mittagsessen mitnehme nach Frankfurt, muss ich sagen, bin
ich natürlich auch schneller fertig, was Mittagspause und sowas angeht. Logischerweise, weil man
nicht rausgehen muss und länger was essen. Aber ich vertrage das auch deutlich besser
als vieles essen. Ich habe übrigens eine praktische Webseite gefunden, als hätte ich jetzt irgendwie
ein super krasses Secret ausgebundelt, aber es gibt sowas, wie hieß das? Verbraucherfenster
oder sowas? Ich verbraune, ich verbraune Verbraucherfenster Hessen, genau. Und da kann
man gucken, da gab es so eine Map, oh fuck, wo ist das denn? Da gab es so eine Map, ja
genau. Da gibt es eine Map, wo schon, bei welchen Restaurants Hygienemängel und Sachen
gemeldet wurden. Ja, das finde ich ganz praktisch. Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal dahin geht,
äh, dachte eigentlich, man könnte, kann man, kann man das nicht irgendwie Fullscreen machen
vielleicht? Äh, Fullscreen ist, Webdesigner hatten keinen Bock mehr. So, zumindest kann
man dann hier reinscrollen und stellt fest, ach guck mal da, Frankfurter Innenstadt, Bahnhofsviertel,
was haben wir denn hier? Carmon Sushi Bar, da war ich zum Beispiel sogar schon essen,
oder was haben wir denn hier? Da war ich noch nicht, ja. Gehen wir zum Beispiel mal hier
gucken, dann sieht man dann, aha, Carmon Sushi Bar, Art der Beanstandung, Produktname, die
Betriebsräume waren so stark verunreinigt, dass eine Grundreinigung aller Geräte, es
wurde ein Mäuse sowie ein Schabenbefall festgestellt. Ja. Also, die hatten Mäuse und Schaben, geil.
Also, insofern, perfekt für die Almans. Ich weiß nicht, möchten nicht Almans gerne
Mäuse, Mäusekacke und, und, äh, Kakerlaken fressen? Ich weiß nicht, ob das, ob das tatsächlich
die Leute gibt, die das gerne machen. Kann ja sein. Ähm, die in der Betriebsschule Herkestellfarm
und Verkehr waren eine, waren einer Kontaminationsgefahr ausgesetzt, Schaukirche Sushi. Also, sprich,
insofern kann man da ganz gut, kann man da ganz gut sehen, ähm, was es so gab. Und ich
hab auch, ich werd es jetzt nicht zeigen, erstens, weil es bei mir in der Nähe ist und
zweitens, weil ich, ähm, ne, eigentlich nur, weil es bei mir in der Nähe ist, sonst würde
ich zeigen. Ich hab bei dem Laden geguckt, wo ich bestellt habe, wo ich vermute, dass
ich meine Lebensmittelvergiftung bekommen habe. Also, ich hab ja, ich hatte ja vor,
war noch vor Corona, vor einer ganzen Weile hatte ich ja meine Lebensmittelvergiftung
und zwar mit Cam, wie heißt das Ding? Cam-Phylo-Bacter. Ja, das hatte ich. Und da war ja meine Vermutung,
da war ja meine Vermutung, dass ich das, ähm, vom bestellten Rahmschnitzel bekommen hab,
weil das war ja das Einzige, was ich die letzten Tage über dort, äh, irgendwie verdächtiges
bestellt habe und ich hab mal in diesem, auf dieser Map geguckt, also im Prinzip kriegt
man davon richtig krass Dünnschiss, ja. Pepo-Pupu-Fire-Toilet. Toilet-Toilet, wie war es das? Toilet-Toilet-Zoom.
So hier, das dann aus, genau so. Ja, äh, zumindest hab ich bei, also nicht, nicht hier,
nicht hier, ja. Zumindest hab ich bei dem Laden geschaut, wo ich das, wo ich das bekommen
hab, wo ich was bestellt hab und der Laden ist voll, der ist voll, also da ist das hier
noch wenig, die haben wirklich fünf Seiten voll mit Hygienemängel und es stand auch
dabei, dass die zum größten Teil noch nicht beseitigt waren, also das find ich ganz gut,
hier kann man, guck mal hier, ist übrigens der KFC an der Hauptwache, das wundert mich
auch nicht. Mäuse, guck mal hier, der Unterbau der Pizzausgabe, so wie die Arbeitsfläche
im Bereich der Getränkespender, waren mit Mäusekot verschmutzt, das ist alles Zeug,
das darf nicht passieren, ich mein, die müssen ihren Kram sauber machen und die müssen auch
gucken, dass sie da in der Küche nicht so viel Dreck rumliegen haben, dass da sich Mäuse
und Kakerlaken und alles. Äh, ey, das kann so echt nicht sein. Also das hab ich mir schon
gebookmarkt auf dem Handy und das erste, was ich machen werde, falls ich mal wieder in
irgendeinen neuen Laden gehe, ich werd da gucken, ob das nicht irgendwelche Einträge
hat. Also hier war ich, hier war ich noch nirgendswo, hier war ich auch noch nie, was haben wir
hier, war ich auch noch nie, Kochi-Bazaar, Mr. Klu war ich auch noch nicht, Hotpot, bin
ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, da könnte ich vielleicht sogar, da könnte ich sogar mal
drinnen gewesen sein. Es wurde, es wurde Lebensmittel, es wurde ein Lebensmittel in
den Verkehr gebracht, das für den menschlichen Verzehr nicht geeignet war und eine Erkrankung
von nachweislich 65 Personen nach sich zog. Also das hätt so Sachen, das willst du wahrscheinlich,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob das das Ding gewesen ist, wo ich schon drinnen war. Hm,
sieht jetzt anders aus, ist das das, wo man so ne Wendeltreppe drinnen hoch muss? Ja,
da war ich schon, das ist das, wo man so ne Wendeltreppe hoch muss, da war ich, da hab
ich noch mal Glück gehabt, hab ich noch mal Glück gehabt. Also mich hat's noch nicht
sicher mich, da war ich aber schon. Also kann ich echt empfehlen, einfach mal zu gucken,
bevor man futtern geht. Schweizers Döner, ja aber die Schweizer auch Döner machen.
Da war ich irgendwann mal, aber das. Der Feinkost Ebert, was die sich unter Feinkost
vorstellen. Also kann man auf jeden Fall mal gucken, es ist nicht verkehrt, geht für
ganz Hessen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele andere Bundesländer mittlerweile auch
so was haben. Kannste machen. Das ist wahrscheinlich rechtlich nicht so einfach und es ist ja irgendwo
auf, ja ich weiß nicht, ob es sinnvoll ist, quasi bei Kleinigkeiten, quasi auch Restaurants,
die es irgendwie seit 3-4 Jahren gibt und nie was verkehrt gemacht haben, die sich jetzt
mal einen Fehltritt geleistet haben oder sowas nicht zu machen. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie da
die rechtliche Lage ist, das muss ja auch nicht sein. Deswegen finde ich das wirklich
eine coole Sache mit der Map. Also bei dieser, erinnert sich noch einer an diese ganze Gammelfleisch
Geschichte, da wurde bei uns wirklich ein Laden dicht gemacht, in der Nähe, so ein
Sicherladen, bei dem war ich mittags auch öfters. Und da habe ich mir schon ein bisschen
Gedanken gemacht. Aber ich hatte, aber ich muss halt sagen, ich habe das Essen in Frankfurt
an vielen Läden nicht vertragen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich davon richtig
krank geworden wäre oder kotzen musste oder so, aber ich habe es gemerkt, also seitdem
ich nicht mehr in Frankfurt Mittagessen gehe, habe ich viel seltener Bauchweh und Dünnschiss
und alles Mögliche. Also es hat schon ein bisschen was damit zu tun. So. Lebensmittelkontrollapp.
Hier ist alles drin, oder wie? Hier ist nur. Ach nee, doch. Okay, gucken wir mal. Schauen
wir mal, ob das hier sich deckt. Alter, was ist das wieder für Frankfurt? Das hört ja
gar nicht mehr auf, Alter. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Kackel, Alter. Da weißt du
ja gar nicht, was du anklicken sollst. Ach Moment. Zu den Berichten. Ach nee, da kann
man was. Aber was? Was ist das jetzt für einen Sinn? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Also was soll mir das sagen? Da erkennt man ja gar nichts zu. Kann man dort quasi, wenn
man irgendwie Verdacht hat, dort geht was nicht mit richtigen Dingen zu petzen oder
was? Die grünen Eichens. Zu den Berichten. Ach so, okay, das grüne ist quasi auffällig
gewesen. Oh Gott, das kenne ich. Da war ich schon. Okay, zu den Berichten. Soll ich das
jetzt, seriously, konnte man das nicht irgendwie digitalisieren oder was? Alter, Deutschland
2023, Mann. Was? The fuck, Alter, ist das jetzt euer Ernst oder wie? Das kann doch
keiner lesen. Damit kann man jetzt wirklich nichts anfangen. Vielleicht einmal Chat-GPT
fragen, ob die das versteht. Wobei die macht ja kein OCR. Das ist wirklich weirdchamp.
Okay, was können wir uns jetzt angucken? Zeig mal her. Ach, der Straßenbaumeister,
da waren wir ja gerade dabei. Ist ein bisschen sidetracked worden, minimal. Minimaler sidetrack.
Und dann geht's los. 7 Uhr ist jetzt in dem Fall Dienstbeginn. Dann versuche ich das
immer so schon einzurichten, dass ich zu Hause so losfahre, dass ich an der ersten Baustelle
um 7 Uhr bin. Ja gut. Ist sinnvoll, wenn es da anfängt, auch da zu sein. Wobei 7 Uhr
da sein, da musst du je nachdem, wo die Baustelle ist, musst du da teilweise wahrscheinlich
auch schon um 5.30 Uhr oder so aufstehen. Ich bin für den Aufgabenbereich Aufgabung
zuständig. Bedeutet Versorger, Telekommunikationsunternehmen und wenn die Störungen haben, die müssen
die Fahrbahnen öffnen, die Störungen beseitigen, dann bin ich dafür zuständig, dass das ordnungsgemäß
wiederhergestellt wird. Aha. Hier hat die Telekom eine Baumaßnahme gehabt, wahrscheinlich
eine Störung. Wie? Gar kein gelbes Signalwestchen. Noch gar nicht wiederhergestellt. Die Baugrube
ist noch offen, wenn wir nochmal wiederkommen, wenn es fertig ist. Die Telekom beauftragt
die Firmen, die Firmen kommen raus, beseitigen die Schaden, geben der Telekom wieder Bescheid,
die sind fertig und somit meldet sich Telekom wieder bei uns und sagt, wir sind fertig,
fahren mal vorbei, Übernahme etc. Oder lass uns draußen treffen zusammen. Also Loch ist
immer noch da. Hier vorne hatten wir den Bereich, auch wieder von der Telekom und hier haben
wir Pflaster. Hier schauen wir einfach nur, ob alles vernünftig wiederhergestellt wurde.
Das ist eigentlich ein geiler Job, du guckst die Baustellen von anderen Leuten an und guckst
drauf und dann gehst du wieder. Wahrscheinlich gehört aber noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Eben eine Fläche haben, ob die Fugen richtig verfüllt sind, ob der Verband eingehalten
wurde. Hier passt, hier sieht alles oberflächlich, alles okay aus. Die Firma, die auch hier gebaut
hat, das ist eine vernünftige Firma. Keine Kacknubs, die das gebaut haben. Für die paar Meter,
die ich noch zusätzlich jetzt fahre, so wie jetzt, das ist ja alles auf dem Weg zum Betriebshof.
Warum spatzt der immer so? Damit mein Privatfahrzeug zu benutzen. Eigentlich sieht man das relativ
schnell. Wenn der Asphalt neu ist, sieht man das gegenüber einen älteren Asphalt, älteren
Flicken. Aber hier müssen wir wirklich noch mal gucken. Ich schaue mal da drüben. Abmahnung
ist raus. Gefunden. Direkt neu aufmachen, neu machen. Ob die Nähte richtig zu sind,
dicht sind, weil wenn wir halt irgendwo einen Spalt haben, kann Wasser eindringen. Im Winter
gefriert das. Oder die Leute fallen aufs Maul. Das ist im Kollege von mir auf der Armband
beim Heimweg passiert. Da war so eine Bodenplatte, also so eine Kachel im Gehweg war nicht richtig
fest. Und da war ein Loch drunter. Weiß ich, ob da irgendjemand geprankt hatte oder so.
Das wäre ein ziemlich bösartiger Prank. Der ist zumindest auf die Bodenplatte gedreht,
also auf diese Fliese vom Gehweg und ist dann mit dem Bein da reingefallen und hat sich
direkt das Knie aufgeritzt am Stein. Auch ganz toll. Ich empfinde meinen Job als sehr
wichtig, weil irgendeiner muss da sein, der das kontrolliert. Sonst hätten wir einen
wilden Westen hier, wenn wir keinen haben, der danach geht und sagt alles. Okay, jetzt
siehst du Leute, jetzt ist er offiziell, jetzt hat er nämlich seine Signalweste an. Moin.
Jetzt hat er seine Signalweste an, jetzt ist es vorbei. Jetzt Schluss mit lustig. Das hast
du gut gemacht bzw. das hast du schlecht gemacht. Ja, sieht vernünftig aus. Gut. Gut. Also zeig
mal her, was hat er gemacht? Der hat gelernt, Einzelhandelskaufmann, dann hat er als Einzelhandelskaufmann
gearbeitet, dann hat er Straßen... Moment, was? Straßenunterhaltungsarbeiter gelernt,
da wäre ich überhaupt nicht... Bisher hätte ich überhaupt nicht gewusst, dass es das überhaupt
gibt. Dann hat er Ausbildung Straßenwärter gemacht, das hört sich fast schon irgendwie
was aus dem Gefängnis an, aber so heißt das anscheinend. Straßenwärter und Vorarbeit,
dann ist er zum Straßenbaumeister. Ah, da ging es rund. Das Büro befindet sich...
Das hat er innerhalb von 15 Jahren gemacht. Was habe ich in 15 Jahren gemacht? Immer
noch das Gleiche. Da ist das Parken ziemlich bescheiden und deswegen, mit dem Dienstwagen
ist es dann doch schon angenehmer. Da sind wir in den heiligen Hallen. Guck mir die Sachen
an, die jetzt reingekommen sind nach Feierabend oder in der Nachtstörung etc. Guck, ob andere
reingekommen sind. Das ist jetzt das Straßenmonitoring quasi. Da haben wir eine Aufbruchmeldung,
der Ablauf ist der, dass z.B. ein Rohr ausgetauscht werden muss. Alter, mich nervt das unglaublich,
dass er nach jedem Satz so schmatzt. Manch einer wird vielleicht sagen, halbes ASMR-Video.
Aber er hat ordentlich zwei Monitore, so muss das sein. Ich finde auch, das ist wirklich
Arbeitsplatz, der kann sich sehen lassen. Zwei ordentliche Monitore, so ein halbwegs
modernes Telefon, Smartphone, Tablet-Ständer und so. Das sieht wenigstens nach was aus,
was nicht nach Behörde von vor 20 Jahren schreibt. Ist es Nodes? War es wirklich Nodes? Ich habe
es gar nicht gesehen. War das irgendwie erkannt? Könnte doch alles sein. Wobei, das Rechte,
ne? Ist das No? Das könnte sein. Könnte aber auch Outlook, ne, wobei die Outlook ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht wegen den Tabs hier. Aber das Logo, wie sieht denn das aktuelle Domino-Logo
aus? Das könnte es schon sein, oder? Zack, ist der Antrag vollständig und schon mal bei uns
hinterlegt, dass da jetzt bald eine Baumausnahme stattfindet. Hier haben wir uns das Festjahr
gerade angeguckt gehabt, haben nochmal ein Foto vor Ort gemacht, da war ja alles gut.
Jetzt sehen wir es nicht mehr, ne, das ist auf jeden Fall kein Nodes da unten. Ne, das im
Hintergrund ist es, ist das, jetzt sehen wir es ja im Hintergrund, ne. Wobei, doch Leute,
das könnte schon Nodes sein im Hintergrund da, ne? Das ist Nodes? Das da ist Nodes, wirklich?
Okay, das Eichen hätte ich jetzt nicht Nodes zugeordnet, aber im Hintergrund hier mit diesem
Kalender und diesem hässlichen Zeug an der Seite, das ist Nodes, ja. Jetzt kann ich
dann... Oh, das ist ja gar nicht mehr IBM und das ist auch nicht mehr Lotus, das ist,
was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Wer bietet diesen Crap denn noch an? Oh, 10 nach 10 schon,
also schon 10 Minuten über die Frühstückszeit. Aber hapa, ACL, aha. Frühstück immer vegetarisch,
also kein Fleisch beim Frühstück, dann versuche ich das immer mit was Gesunden zu verbinden und
natürlich was Süßes. Tomaten zum Frühstück hätte ich persönlich keinen Bock drauf,
aber jeder, was er gerne isst, ja. Relativ ruhig, ne, aber manchmal ist es wirklich so,
dass man zwei, drei Mal, obwohl man eigentlich Büroarbeit ausführen möchte, zwei, drei Mal
trotzdem rausfahren muss. Also immer rein zum Auto, raus zum Termin, dann wieder zurück,
dann legt man das durch, dann ruft wieder einer an, raus, ne. Haben wir alles? Haben wir.
Aber viele andere Leute gibt es da nicht, oder? Am meisten Spaß macht mir aktuell komischerweise
die Rufbereitschaft. Da muss man hinfahren und dann sofort agieren, sofort irgendwas erledigen und
machen, damit es verkehrssicher ist und dahingehend mache ich es sehr, sehr gerne. Leider nur dreimal
im Jahr. Er ist einfach zu agil für diese Welt. Lass dich den Chef nicht hören. Vielleicht
darf ich ja noch öfters. Wir fahren jetzt zur Kastruper Straße. Da wurde ich gestern angerufen
von der Telekom. Der hat da Fragen bezüglich der Wiederherstellung. Morgen. Mahlzeit. Ich dachte,
hier bist du schon zu Gange an dem Ding. Ah, ist der Glasfaser. Hi. Hallo. Hi. Um was geht's?
Für meinen Job sollte man mitbringen. Einsatzbereitschaft, handwerkliches Geschick.
Musste er überhaupt schon mal was selbst machen heute? Na gut, auf der anderen Seite
es ist sinnvoll, wenn du selbst weißt, wie es richtig geht. Ist egal, ob du das noch selbst
machst. Du solltest schon selbst wissen, so ungefähr, wie was ordentlich aussehen muss.
Und das weißt du wahrscheinlich am besten, wenn du es selbst schon mal gemacht hast.
So ein bisschen Troubleshooting. Also, dass man wirklich so Probleme schnell aus der Welt schaffen
kann. Wir können mal gucken, wie es hier vorne aussieht. Aber hier sieht es ja noch gut aus und
da würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, dass wir hier schießen würden. Ich kann ja soweit Bescheid
geben, dass die die Baugrube offen lassen. Du dann schießt und dann... Wer schießt? Auf was wird da
geschossen? Aber dann habt ihr wenigstens weniger Arbeit schon mal mit Öffnen. Ja, das wäre vielleicht
ganz nett. Alles klar. Okay. Ich mach Bescheid und dann melde ich mich bei den Kollegen. Wir sehen uns.
Alles klar. Mach's gut. Danke dir. Ciao. Weiter geht's. Da hatten wir halt diese Baumaßnahme gehabt,
dass da das Pflaster... Ja, und was haben die da jetzt gemacht? Also, außer dass er schießt...
...ausgenommen wurde und beim Rausnehmen beschädigt wurde. Zu wirklich checken, was jetzt da eigentlich
genau passiert, habe ich nicht. Die Enten kaputt, Fugen rausgefahren, alles abgesackt. Das muss auf
jeden Fall neu gemacht werden. Das können wir nicht so lassen. Abmahnung. Im Endeffekt
trefft die Entscheidung nicht für mich selber, sondern da hängt noch die Firma dran, der
Auftraggeber da dran. Das sind halt Gelder, die halt durch eine Falschentscheidung verloren gehen.
Aus dem Grund habe ich eine hohe Verantwortung gegenüber den Bürgern bzw. den Steuernzahlern.
Mach ich noch mal ein Foto von dem Pflaster. Die Maße habe ich schon. Und jetzt fahren wir mal zum
Lagerplatz und gucken, ob wir das eingelagert haben. Wir haben oftmals Mindestbestellmengen,
die wir abnehmen müssen für Pflaster und lagern die dann ein für solche Fälle, wenn mal irgendwas
beschädigt wird oder sowas, das man halt einen Ersatz mal da hat. So, der Osten Hellweg. Das war auch zum
größten Teil beschrieben, dass wir mal die Schilder davor haben, damit wir wissen, alles klar,
das ist jetzt zum Beispiel der Osten Hellweg. Da vorne haben wir den Wilhelm.
Mist, misst der jetzt die Platten, oder?
Aber es kommt mal vor, dass eine Palette einfach irgendwo anders hingestellt wird,
deswegen muss man ein bisschen schauen. Hab sie. Ging schneller als gedacht. Also manchmal dauert
sogar noch länger. Jetzt habe ich sie. Dann kann ich der Firma Bescheid geben, dass wir auf jeden
Fall eine Palette noch da haben. Ich verdiene aktuell nach TVÖD 4000 Euro brutto. Da kommen
durch verschiedene andere Dienste, wie zum Beispiel die Rufbereitschaft oder das Absperren.
Das ist ja durchaus. Kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren? Das ist schon okay.
Kommt dann noch mal was drauf, teilweise auch steuerfrei. Und somit bin ich bei 4300 Euro netto.
Das ist doch in Ordnung. Kannst du dich da nicht beschweren?
Wir sind nicht verbeamtet. Wir sind angestellt. Verbeamtet wird man nicht mehr so einfach,
wie es damals mal war. Das ist ein Irrglaube, dass man halt bei der Stadt arbeitet,
sofort Beamter ist. Das ist nicht so.
Und vom Sparen her, wo steckst du es da rein?
Einmal in Fonds, also in ein Depot und leider in Kripto.
Naja, 100 Euro monatlich in irgendwelche spekulativen Sachen. Das ist doch kein Ding.
Kann man doch machen. Ich meine, vielleicht bringt es ja mal irgendwie richtig was und
wenn es weg ist, ist es auch nicht so schlimm. So, jetzt checken wir noch mal, ob neue Mails
reingekommen sind. Im besten Fall. Nein, können wir nämlich weiter machen.
Hat sich bestimmt mehr gelohnt als meine Stonks dieses Jahr.
Glück gehabt. Wir fahren jetzt einmal an die 16. Etage. Da sitzt der Kollege und der
hat einen Donut für mich. Dafür kann man schon mal in den 16.
Stock fahren. Ich wäre wahrscheinlich jeden Tag im 16.
Stock, wenn es da immer Donuts geben würde. Wo ist der Donut?
Hallo. Tach, Chef, wir wollten dich jetzt weiterarbeiten.
Was dein Aufgabenbereich ist und... Nein, wir haben dir einen Gag erlaubt.
Auch Post noch. Sehr gut. Alles klar. Danke.
Dann gleich schön Feierabend euch, ne? Danke. Ciao, ciao.
Den Schaden habe ich entdeckt. Eine angefahrene Pfosten.
Oh, okay. Das ist natürlich auch cool, wenn du durch die Stadt fährst und siehst, dass
was kaputt ist. Ich sehe laufend das, was kaputt ist.
Da kannst du jedes Mal sagen, aha, aha, ihr müsst was gemacht haben. Das ist natürlich
nicht schlecht. Da würde ich zum Beispiel mal den Parkplatz
hier in der Nähe mal neu die Löcher ausbessern lassen und so was.
Wir melden mal ganz kurz die Rufbereitschaft. Das passiert auch manchmal, dass man zufällig
halt an Schaden vorbeikommt. Dann ruft man halt die Rufbereitschaft an und die fahren
dann nochmal raus und stellen das Verkehr sicher wieder her.
Aber immer im Dienst. Was macht denn die Rufbereitschaft dann?
Ich meine, es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als würde da jetzt unmittelbar was Schlimmes passieren,
wenn der Pfosten da so steckt. Machen die dann ein Foto davon und sagen,
okay, ich habe es mir angeguckt, wir schicken jetzt einen Auftrag an eine Baufirma raus.
Das kann jetzt nicht erst am nächsten Arbeitstag passieren, oder wie?
Rufbereitschaft an und die fahren dann nochmal raus und stellen das Verkehr sicher wieder
her. Aber immer im Dienst, also auch privat muss man sagen. Also wenn ich privat irgendwo
in Dortmunder Raum unterwegs bin, würde ich sowas natürlich auch sofort melden.
Also das Heftigste, was ich in der Rufbereitschaft hatte, das war, dass eine komplette Straße
abgesackt ist. Also wirklich 100 Meter ungefähr oder 80 Meter.
Oh! Oho!
Das ist komplett abgesackt, komplett zusammengefallen und dann...
Alter! Wie... Wie kann denn sowas passieren?
Ist da irgendwie Kanalisation eingebrochen oder wie?
Meter ungefähr oder...
Oder unterschwemmt oder so? Wie kann denn sowas passieren?
80 Meter waren es, es ist komplett abgesackt, komplett zusammengefallen und dann musste
man alles drumherum absperren, eine Umleitung...
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, sowas.
... das mal zu sehen, wie die Straße langsam auch sackt. Das hat man immer noch gesehen,
das war schon extrem.
So, da sind wir wieder. Schon offen.
Hallo!
Machst du dir nichts?
Nee, ich habe ja schon gegessen.
Ach so. Das ist nicht gestellt, also ich bekomme wirklich jeden Tag. Feierabend bekomme
ich das Essen.
Im Endeffekt haben wir einen Abtrag von 900 Euro, wenn man alles zusammenrechnet und dafür
haben wir 156 Quadratmeter, 600 Quadratmeter Grundstück und das ist schon ganz gut.
Wir wollten zuerst gar nicht mehr, weil wir so gesucht haben und wir haben nichts gefunden
gehabt. Der Markt hat nichts für uns da gehabt bzw. nur zu horrenden Preisen und dann auf
einmal...
Ok, Chet weiß wieder Bescheid, der Chet sagt, das wird als Baustelle gekennzeichnet, damit
die Stadt rechtlich abgesehen ist. Ah ja, ok, da wird dann quasi irgendein Warnhütchen
hingestellt, dass man sie nicht verklagen kann, dass man da jetzt dagegen gerannt ist
oder so.
Dann haben wir Glück gehabt, dann haben wir zugegriffen.
Na, dafür machen wir das ja alles. Ob es Arbeit ist, ob es Geld verdient ist, ob es
die Freizeit ist, klar nimmt man sich natürlich ein bisschen was raus, aber ansonsten geht
alles für die Familie, was auch richtig so ist.
Da hat doch bestimmt das Kamerateam gesagt, können sie sich mal mit der ganzen Familie
jetzt vor das Barbie-Haus setzen und so tun, als würden sie da was machen.
Richtig und wichtig.
Richtig und wichtig, ja.
Oh, geht noch was.
Ja, das Geld wird dann wieder drauf gemacht, ja.
das geld wird dann mit sicherheit auch ausgeben für kinderfamilie urlaub alles mögliche dann
geht ja auch noch einiges drauf
jetzt wird es wird noch was von erzählen es ist ein sparplan krypto für die kinders
aufs konto alles klar so wirklich was ein straßenbaum-meister macht habe ich jetzt
nicht so nicht wirklich verstanden der guckt sich die sachen an macht ein foto und drückt
bei anträgen auf ja und nein oder sowas irgendwie sehr gut
es eher auf sehr ja so in der richtung hätte ich hätte ich jetzt auch hätte ich jetzt
auch gesehen irgendjemand muss ja auch die verantwortung tragen aber dann sonst noch
ok wir kommen uns jetzt an neue neue neuen neue ai tools die unser mind blown werden
gatchibas dass wir unser mind blown auf geht's das blasen
das fängt ja schon wieder an
ok ok ok ok weiter im text jetzt erstes ai tool
auf kommt zum punkt
kenne ich das kenne ich das habe ich das habe ich tatsächlich bei hackernews mal gesehen
da kannst du also wenn das das ist wenn das das ist was ich das habe ich das habe ich
vor vor ein zwei monaten also glaube ich auf hackernews gesehen da kannst du quasi reinschreiben
so sinngemäß was du sagen willst und dann kannst du kannst du kannst du sagen ok mach
mir daraus beispielsweise ein eine eine eine förmliche ein förmlichen brief oder sowas
ja da kann ich reinschreiben chat sagt sagt dem chat sie gehen mir auf den sack weil sie
weil sie zu sehr backseiten und dann macht dann dieses tool daraus sehr geehrte damen
und herren ihr backseiting übersteigt ein annehmbares level oder sowas das habe ich
auf stack overflow gesehen nicht auf stack overflow auf hackernews gesehen habe ich stack
overflow gesagt auf hackernews gesehen vor zwei drei monaten oder ein zwei monaten
mainly things like emails it's quite similar to chat gpt i think it uses that technology
but obviously you've got to go over to chat gpt you've got to type in your stuff this is
actually working in my browser all the time and i'll just show you how this works now
so i'll head over to my email
dass das alleine im browser arbeitet habe ich so meine zweifel das macht bestimmt requests
zu irgendwelchen cloud services
und das ist ein e-mail das ich von jemanden bekomme ich kann mich nicht auf eine volle e-mail
schreiben
das tool gucken wir mal wie hieß dieses ding noch mal compose compose ai nicht nicht add
ok es gibt eine premium version damit verdienen die wahrscheinlich was und wo gibt es die
premium version wahrscheinlich wenn man es installiert hat kann man wahrscheinlich auswählen
dass man premium abschließen will
ja ich finde das video nicht mehr ich habe zu viele tabs offen
eigentlich ist das eine richtig coole Sache
wenn man öfters irgendwelche förmlichen sachen schreiben muss und kein bock hat jedes
mal sich da irgendwas aus den fingern zu sagen
das ist ok das haben wir schon viele auf youtube
ist das herr tutorial da unten
nee oder nee nee nee sah bloß auf den ersten blick so aus
dieses tool haben ja schon ganz viele leute auf youtube
ein
Ich bin ziemlich enttäuscht, um ehrlich zu sein.
Es ist ziemlich schrecklich, denn es ist fast wie ein tiefes Faken für deine Stimme.
Also denkst du, wenn es in die falschen Hände kommt, was können sie mit diesem machen?
Aber es ist wirklich cool und ich zeige dir, wie es funktioniert.
Also um das zu benutzen, musst du die D-Script-App auf deinen Computer downloaden.
Und wenn du es benutzen willst, kann es immer wieder deine Wörter produzieren, so wie das.
Erleicht die Wörter-Affiliate.
Jetzt spielen wir von hier.
Schreib auf Demand und alles dazwischen.
Jetzt gehen wir rein.
Ich meine, das hört sich wirklich gut an. Das haben wir aber schon in ein paar anderen Videos gesehen.
Okay, nächstes. Wir skippen das mal, da ist viel Blablabla dabei.
Wir schauen immer weiter, damit ihr das hören könnt.
Das nächste Tool, das ich euch zeigen werde, ist Epic.
Und es ist nicht nur ein Tool, es ist eine Schicht AI-Magie.
Es ist ein Tool ML und du kannst einen Free-Account holen.
Okay Leute, ich skippe mal ein bisschen durch. Was haben wir als nächstes?
Es ist ein Tool, den wir vor ein paar Tagen gesehen haben.
Und es ist eigentlich ein Tool, das ein Video bringt, um dich direkt zurück zu bringen.
Oder ein News-Artikel, das du geschrieben hast.
Es ist ein App, das alles, was du gesehen, gesagt oder gehört hast, wirklich erinnert.
Ähm, ich will, ich will definitiv...
Das alles, was du...
Ich will definitiv kein Cloud-Service, was alles, was du gesehen, gesagt oder gehört hast, erinnert.
Sehen, gesagt oder gehört. Es ist ziemlich revolutionär.
Und es ist verrückt, was diese Leute tun.
Also, es ist dieses hier, es heißt rewind.ai.
Und sie bezahlen es als Search-Engine für dein Leben.
Was es tut, ist, dass es alles, was du auf deinem Computer rekordt.
Was?
Videos, die du siehst, Web-Pages, die du besuchst und Noten, die du kreierst und Discords, die du schreibst.
Es rekordiert alles.
Was zum...
Warum sollte man sich sowas, wenn man noch halbwegs normal im Kopf ist, überhaupt jemals...
Ähm...
Und dann in der Cloud...
Ach du Scheiße, man!
Warum?
Das ist nichts für mich, ja.
Das würde ich mir eh im Leben noch nicht installieren, man.
Übrigens, das mit dem Transkreiben...
Wer jetzt denkt, das können nur super krasse Cloud-Anbieter...
Soll ich euch mal was zeigen?
Wo man auch wieder sieht, dass wir hier die meisten High-IQ-Leute auf...
Also, most High-IQ im Durchschnitt auf ganz Twitch haben.
Passt mal auf.
Wenn ihr in mein VOD-Archiv geht...
Und...
Was weiß ich hier, irgendwie...
PC zusammenbauen, von vorne im Monat aufmacht...
Und dann könnt ihr hier unten...
Passt mal auf.
Dann könnt ihr hier unten Transcribe anmachen...
Und siehe da...
Wir haben automatisch generiertes Zeug, was ich sage.
Und noch besser ist, man kann das Transcript auch...
Bekommt das als Timestamps...
Und kann es durchsuchen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt in die Suche gehe...
Und danach irgendwie richtig oder so suche...
Dann finde ich Sachen, wo ich schon im Video das Wort richtig verwendet habe.
Da kann ich sogar...
Also, das ist mega mega High-IQ-technisch gemacht hier.
Kann man sogar da draufklicken und ich komme auf den Timestamp, wo ich das sage.
Das ist richtig krass.
Damit, ohne Scheiß, dass es mittlerweile so advanced, was er da gebaut hat...
Damit könnte man theoretisch sogar Geld verdienen.
Und...
Wie das Ganze funktioniert ist...
Wer hat das gebaut?
TheSeriesMax...
Modge hat das gebaut.
Und wie das funktioniert ist...
Die Videos werden in der Cloud analysiert.
Mit einer fetten Kiste, mit GPUs drinnen.
Per Machine Learning.
Das läuft auf einer Kiste.
Ich glaube, da ist aktuell eine 3090 TI oder sowas drin.
Oder zwei 3090 TI.
Also, die Kiste ist ein bisschen teurer.
Ich überlege gerade, was das gekostet hat.
Ich bezahle das unregelmäßig.
Habe ich ihm was überwiesen dafür.
Also, ich glaube, das Initiale Konvertieren aller Videos hat, glaube ich, zwei Wochen gedauert.
Und hat am Ende 500 Euro gekostet.
Oder 400 Euro oder sowas.
Also, zwei Wochen, GPU, Cloud, Computer.
Also, es war jetzt schon nicht ganz billig.
Aber, ich meine, es war irgendwas mit Dual oder vielleicht im Monat.
Es kann auch sein, dass es im Monat gekostet hätte.
400 Euro im Monat oder sowas.
Also, es ist nicht ganz billig.
Richtig und wichtig.
Kommt nicht so oft vor, dass ich das gesagt habe, oder?
Also, das würde ich mir im Leben nicht installieren.
Jetzt immer seriously.
Ich installiere mir doch kein Tool, was alles aufzeichnet, was bei mir auf dem Rechner ist.
Okay, ich habe Windows.
Da könnte man jetzt sagen, das macht es ja eh schon.
Also, ist es nicht schlimm?
Wie häufig sagst du Schlingel?
Okay, mal das mal nachprobieren.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Der Schlingel.
Der Schlingel habe ich tatsächlich gesagt.
Ich habe den Chat vorgelesen.
Gaben der Schlingel.
Oder ein News-Artikel, das du über Krypto geredet hast.
Das ist ziemlich revolutionär.
Ich bin davon enttäuscht.
Wie oft hast du Gatchibuzz gesagt?
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Wisst ihr von was ich blown away bin?
Dass Leute allen Ernstes das benutzen.
Da bin ich blown away.
Ich habe oft Gatchibuzz gesagt.
Aber nicht oft genug anscheinend.
Ich habe sicherlich öfters Gatchibuzz gesagt als hier.
Das ist, wo er Gatchibuzz erkannt hat.
Okay, wir switchen mal zum nächsten Tool, was unser Mind blowt.
Okay.
Ah, das kenne ich.
Das ist ein Powerpoint-Generator.
Und so ein Slide-Generator.
Das wollte ich tatsächlich schon mal ausprobieren.
Okay, das machen wir jetzt mal.
Tom.app.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus zusammen.
Get Tom for free.
Nicht mit Google.
Create one.
E-mail address.
Okay.
Ten minute mail.
Das da.
Beste.
E-mail address.
Ich denke mir jetzt mal kurz irgendein Passwort aus.
Alles klar.
Continue.
Max, what's your role?
Komm, wir machen mal.
Wir machen mal.
Gibt es irgendwie technology oder creative customer support engineering?
Next.
Verify your email.
Alles klar.
Ist der neue PC schon angeschlossen?
Ja, klar.
Sonst hätte ich nicht Windows 11.
Ha, she baited.
Oh, nee.
Filtern die Fake-Mails vielleicht raus?
Kann das sein?
Okay.
Ja, manchmal geht es auch.
Pricing.
Pricing, pricing.
Ich würde, ich würde es gerne tryen.
Aha.
Verify your email address.
Confirm my account.
Jawohl.
Excellent.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt die Seite prokken.
Oder liegt es am Dark Reader vielleicht?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Okay, machen wir es mal im Chrome.
Vielleicht funktioniert es jetzt im Chrome.
Vielleicht funktioniert es jetzt im Chromium aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Ach so, was hatte ich jetzt für eine E-Mail Adresse?
Funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Excellent.
Mal Firefox ausprobieren.
Richtig mind blowing würde ich sagen.
Extrem mind blowing.
Hyper mind blowing.
Sign in.
Don't save.
Nee, Firefox ist auch kaputt.
Und es liegt auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das blitzt immer kurz auf und ist dann wieder weg.
Es liegt nicht an Uplog.
Ich habe Uplog gerade ausgemacht.
Ich würde sagen, oder was, Beta?
Nee, prokken.
Hyper AI Experience hier.
Funktioniert ja richtig gut.
I verified my E-Mail.
Unlucky.
Ja gut, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt mal auflassen.
Vielleicht tut sich da noch was.
Mal ohne Uplog vielleicht.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Next Level.
Man kann damit automatische Präsentationen generieren.
Daten gelöscht aus dem Browser?
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Muss ich irgendeinen Workspace haben?
Create New Workspace?
Kekke?
Continue.
Okay, wir machen jetzt eine Präsentation.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht AI-generated.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Future of Kekke?
Create.
Okay, Präsentation.
Wollen wir es mal Deutsch machen?
Server Monitoring.
Mal gucken.
Einfach nur Server Monitoring.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was da rauskommt?
Dauert eine Weile.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, glaube ich.
Jetzt kriegen wir eine automatische Präsentation generated für uns.
Die Bilder muss er noch generieren?
Ich meine, es ist keine gute Präsentation.
Alles klar.
Es gibt viel zu viel Text pro Seite.
Gar nicht mal so schlechter Titel.
Ich glaube, auf Deutsch gibt es das noch nicht.
Wir machen das gleich mal auf Deutsch.
Das ist Agenda.
Okay, die Bilder sind ein bisschen creepy.
Was ist Server Monitoring?
Ja.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehen, Alter?
Ich meine...
Hacker-Mans am Rechner.
Ich meine, aber das ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlecht, ja?
Was ist F?
Ah, für mich.
Ich view das.
Okay, es ist halt sehr vage alles, ja?
Es ist halt sehr vage.
Da steht jetzt nicht drin, dass es Zappix, Prometheus und sonst was gibt.
Da steht es halt sehr, sehr vage, alles umschrieben immer.
Okay, da machen wir ein konkretes, machen wir mal was anderes zurück.
Über, da sagen wir mal was Konkretes.
Das können wir nehmen.
Über den Fiat-Champ.
Wir machen, wir versuchen es mal auf Deutsch.
Server Überwachung mit Zappix.
Gucken wir mal, checkt, dass es Deutsch ist.
Nee, nee, nee, ist es nicht, okay.
Können die unterschiedliche Languages?
Nee.
Es ist immer noch relativ ähnliche Muster aufgebaut, ja?
Also es ist, man erkennt schon, dass das immer so ein bisschen so dem gleichen Schema folgt.
Also ein bisschen viel Text, wenn der Tag lang ist, für so ein Slide.
Boah, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Alles klar.
Monitoring your servers with style, okay.
How does Zappix work?
Alter, was sind das für Bilder, man?
Server Überwachung mit Zappix is a powerful monitoring system for all the infrastructure.
Alles klar.
What the fuck?
Ach du Scheiße, man.
Okay.
How to get only high IQ viewers on Twitch.
Maximize your Twitch IQ?
Oh, was?
Understanding high IQ viewers.
High IQ viewers are important.
Okay, also.
Maximizing your Twitch IQ, how to attract high IQ viewers.
Also eins muss ich sagen, die Titel sind nicht schlecht.
Die Titel sind wirklich nicht schlecht.
Understanding high IQ viewers.
Expanding brain.
Es ist halt sehr vage Blabla immer.
Das würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen, dass high IQ viewers anzuziehen.
Der Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist auf Twitch.
Ich würde sagen, high IQ viewers sind eher die Minderheit auf Twitch.
Gamepad, danke schön für den Zapp.
Characteristics of high IQ viewers.
They tend to be analytic, detail oriented, so streamers should focus on the depths of their content.
Das ist halt sehr Blabla.
Es ist sehr vage alles, sehr Blabla.
Haben wir es auch mal ausprobiert.
Nicht, dass man damit jetzt großartig etwas anfangen könnte.
Wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Was hat er als nächstes für ein Tool?
Kann man seinen eigenen Nachrichtensprecher designen?
Also mal gucken, wie gut die Animationen sind.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, die Stimme ist halt Microsoft Sam.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, du erkennst schon, dass es künstlich gemacht ist.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Der bewegt nicht nur den Mund, der hat sich auch sonst bewegt.
Der bewegt sich hier, der bewegt den Kopf ein bisschen, der pflinzelt.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, der bewegt sich hier, der pflinzelt.
Plottwist, das Video ist AI-generated.
Okay, das juckt mich jetzt nicht.
Naja gut, das Video hätte man eigentlich in 3 Minuten machen können, aber man muss es halt auf YouTube strecken.
auf YouTube strecken.
Oah.
Okay, was für eine Hardware ist da drin? Lass mal kurz checken.
Wie heißt das Teil, was er verwendet?
Odyssey... ah, das ist Interlo Power Platform. Ja, das ist eine gute Plattform dafür.
Habe ich auch eine Weile verwendet, nicht für den Router, aber das ist diese...
Das ist quasi eine Weiterentwicklung von den Intel Atomdingern.
Offiziell heißen sie glaube ich mittlerweile auch Celeron, aber das ist ein Low Power Intel x86 Plattform. Es ist tatsächlich eine gute Plattform, aber...
Also...
Den eigenen Router bauen, den Sinn erschließt sich mir immer noch. Egal, guck mal.
Und in diesem Video... Wer sich fragt, wer die CPU ist, die ist da aufgelötet.
Das heißt, wir können das runnen und viele andere Operierungssysteme auf diesem einen Computer.
Wenn Sie mit all diesen...
Moment, jetzt wollen sie Proxmox noch unten drunter machen.
... nach dem Test.
Also, wenn Proxmox mehr über das geht als dieser kleine Typ...
Ich musste einen USB-Adapter verwenden, um beide an Bord NICs an den PFSense-VM zu passen.
Ah, jetzt. Ja, okay. Nein, das ist das alte, was er gebaut hat. Jetzt erzählt er uns, warum das alte Mistwort noch immer was Neues baut.
AliExpress M2 zu Dual-Port.
Ja. Dual-Port 2,5G. Kann man machen.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man das unbedingt noch virtualisieren möchte.
Oh.
Tatsächlich würde ich meinen Router als eine Kiste benutzen, der die routet, sonst nichts.
Deswegen habe ich auch meine Mikrotik-Kiste, mein Mikrotik-Hex-POE.
Der ist im Prinzip nur dafür da, zum Ruten ein bisschen Firewall zu machen.
Und um POE für...
Was macht denn überhaupt noch POE? Ja, für die zwei Access-Points macht er noch POE. Das war's.
Für was? Also, ich habe dieses Ding...
... daheim bei mir.
Kost nicht viel. Gibt es mittlerweile schon Nachfolger von...
... ein gutes...
Ja, aber den... Ich würde da auch kein Piehole drauf betreiben.
Auch da drauf nicht. Das kannst du ja auf deine andere Kiste pappen.
Musst ja nicht auf den Router drauf.
Das Schöne daran ist halt, wenn du nicht alles auf eine Kiste haust,
dann funktioniert dein Internet halt auch noch, wenn diese eine Kiste abkackt.
Ich hatte lange Zeit hier eine fette Server-Kiste stehen.
Da war dann OpenSense drauf mit Netzwerk-Karten.
Und die hat geroutet und so.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich das Ding geroutet habe, hat es kein Internet-Zugang.
Das war halt richtig, richtig dumm.
Jetzt habe ich das alles ein bisschen entzerrt.
Also ich habe beispielsweise den Mikrotik-Router.
Dann habe ich eine Fritz-Box für Deckt noch neben dran.
Dann habe ich zwei Access-Points verteilt, einen im Wohnzimmer, einen im Keller unten.
Im Keller ist noch ein Raspberry Pi für die Heizung zum Datenauslesen
und gucken, ob an der Türgegensprechanlage einer klingelt.
Am 3D-Drucker ist jetzt ein eigener Raspberry Pi.
Ich habe das alles ein bisschen...
Im Wohnzimmer ist eine eigene Kiste jetzt zum Fernsehen gucken.
Wobei, der Shield-TV ist schon lange da.
Aber auch zum Aufnehmen.
Ich habe das alles ein bisschen entzerrt.
Was wirklich den Vorteil hat, wenn diese eine Kiste Probleme hat
oder rebooted werden muss oder mal ein bisschen länger nicht da ist.
Dann geht halt noch alles andere im Haus.
Beziehungsweise ist es ein bisschen unabhängiger.
Hardware, okay.
Ich meine, das Gehäuse ist aber sehr schick.
Das ist nicht selbst gedruckt, oder?
Dafür sieht das zu shiny und zu glatt aus für selbst gedruckt.
Weil das wahrscheinlich auch Metall ist.
Leute, wenn es um abgedrehte Adapter geht, das Geilste, was ich mal bisher hatte,
war M2 auf PCI-Express.
Da hat es so einen M2-Adapter.
Da kam oben ein PCI-Express-Slot.
Da kam oben ein PCI-Express-Slot raus.
sneez
Was kosten das Ding?
Man kann ja durchaus eine coole Plattform sein.
Kann man das überhaupt in Deutschland kaufen?
Wahrscheinlich wieder nicht, oder?
Was sagt denn Amazon dazu?
Oh, die C.
Ey.
Enclosure.
Ja, das Enclosure brauch ich nicht.
Ich brauch die Kiste.
Das Gehäuse?
Was haben die denn da?
Man kann das tatsächlich.
Der Preis hat's aber in sich.
Der Preis hat's aber in dich.
Normalerweise kostet so ein Board 70, 70 Euro.
Ein ähnliches Board kostet 70 Euro.
Der Preis ist wirklich heftig dafür.
Okay, das ist mit SSD und sonst was.
Ohne SSD und ohne RAM?
Es ist immer noch viel zu teuer.
So ein normales Board kostet 70, 80 Euro.
Okay, das war vor der ganzen Inflationsgeschichte.
Gucken wir mal.
Das war zum Beispiel von S-Rock.
Oh, das ist schon ordentlich teurer geworden.
Das ist einfach mal, also wie gesagt, diese Boards kosteten, bevor dieses ganze Inflationszeug
losging, 70, 80 Euro.
Ich hab hier selbst welche gekauft.
Also das war die Vorgänger-Generation, also ich hatte quasi, wie auch immer dieses Vorgänger-Ding
hieß hier.
Irgendwie so.
Aber das ist schon deutlich, deutlich teurer geworden.
Ach, die haben jetzt ein H3.
Ja, das ist schon mal günstig.
Das dumme an den Old-Troid-Dinger ist, die haben kein Gehäuse.
Und das Gehäuse, also doch, die haben Gehäuse, aber das ist einfach nur, also hässlichst
das Gehäuse, was es dafür gibt.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum die den Formfaktor gebaut haben, dass es in kein normales Gehäuse
reinpasst.
Also das offizielle Old-Troid-Gehäuse ist wirklich absolut hässlich, also so mega hässlich.
Das hässlichste Gehäuse, was ich...
Case.
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Das ist so schlecht, das sieht so kacke aus.
Das ist kein Netzteil.
Das ist das Case für das Ding, Mann.
Das sieht wirklich richtig kacke aus, das Teil, Alter.
Also das ist mir zu teuer, das ist mir zu teuer, an sich ist die Plattform wirklich gut, auch
ein ganz guter Ersatz für den Raspberry Pi, weil, also, preislich ähnlich wie ein Raspberry
Pi, aber Leistung deutlich mehr, weil preislich den Raspberry Pi ist halt gerade 3-4 Mal teurer,
als sie eigentlich sein sollten.
Wie stehst du...
Was?
Zu Senf?
Ist das irgendein G-Bait, oder?
Ich meine, wie soll man dazu stehen?
Du meinst, ob ich es esse, oder nicht, ab und zu, ja?
Ich kenne den Unterschied zwischen König oder normal, nicht?
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, das ist irgendein G-Bait, den ich bloß nicht kenne.
Also das Gehäuse und das Board sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal ansprechend aus, aber es ist
viel zu teuer eigentlich für das, was man an Performance kriegt.
Ach ja, wo haben sie denn die CPU hier?
Auf der anderen Seite wahrscheinlich, weil wie gesagt, die CPU ist ja aufgelötet.
Ich habe Proxmox installiert.
Also das ist ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich meine, warum bauen wir einen ultimaten Router, wenn ich ihn nicht benutzen werde?
Na ja, ich will diesen Router eigentlich benutzen, aber ich habe noch nicht so viel Zeit,
um ihn zu benutzen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich etwas brechen werde, und meine Frau hat mich nicht so viel
umsetzen können, wenn ich mit ihrem Computer arbeite.
Na ja, das hätte man sich jetzt auch sparen können.
Ach, die nächste Plattform gibt es auch schon?
Okay, jetzt blick ich da mal durch bei Intel, Low-Power-Zeug.
Intel.
AliExpress ist doch fake, oder?
Gibt es das wirklich schon?
Moment, N5105, ist das nicht noch älter?
Ah, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch, zuviel.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Die 35 besten Dinger, die man auf der Consumer Electronics Show gesehen hat.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal, vielleicht ist auch irgendwas drin, was mich interessiert.
Das letzte Video darüber war ja, da war ja nicht viel dabei, was mich gejuckt hat.
Wir machen es aber im Schnellverfahren.
Also, den haben wir schon gesehen, den haben wir schon gesehen.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Das einzige, was mich da wirklich ansprechen könnte, ist, wenn das mal funktioniert, dass
es einen Rasenmäher gibt, der keine Begrenzungssachen gezogen braucht.
Es gibt ja schon erste Ankündigungen, aber dass einer auch rauskommt und dass der dann
auch gut funktioniert, dann würde ich mir das überlegen.
Also der muss automatisch an das Dock hin und zurück fahren können, der darf nicht
an irgendwelchen Wurzeln laufen und hängen bleiben und der sollte checken, wo fängt
der Garten an, wo hört der Garten auf.
Ich meine, das müsste ja vom Prinzip her eigentlich machbar sein, sei es auch nur mit
GPS.
Dass du mit GPS guckst, wo fängt das Beet an, wo hört das Beet auf.
Klar, mit GPS empfangen ist es vielleicht manchmal zu ungenau, aber das müsste schon
irgendwie gehen.
Dann würde ich mir tatsächlich überlegen, so was zu holen.
Wie lange das ganze hält?
Da wird wahrscheinlich ein Viertel Garten bei mir mähen können oder so.
Eierdetektor, warum reicht kein Rauchdetektor?
In der Regel ist ja das, was brennt, macht auch Rauch und dann kannst du den Rauch detekten.
Also musst du wirklich Feuer detekten?
Reicht das nicht, wenn du den Rauch detektest, weil das funktioniert seit 15-20 Jahren schon
ohne Probleme.
Achso, das ist, dass wenn die Kinder im Kinderzimmer irgendwie... ja okay.
Okay, in der Küche ist es vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, in der Küche kann es
ja kein Rauchmelder hinhängen.
bottoms up.
Ring. Paints Check.
Egal ob im Auto oder nicht im Auto, Ring kommt ja nicht jetzt raus.
Und auch nicht ins Auto.
Egal ob im Auto oder im Auto, Ring kommt ja nicht jetzt raus.
Das ist praktisch, dass man ein Rad zum Dimmen hat.
Ganz ehrlich, so ein Scrollrad ist zum Dimmen wahrscheinlich viel cooler als Hoch- und Unterbutton.
Die Image, die auf der 97-Inch-OLED-TV verwendet wurde, ist unglaublich.
Ich kann diese wireless TV sehen, als wäre sie irgendwo über einem Feuerplatz, wo nur ein Outlet verfügbar wäre.
Mosquitos lieben mich, also wusste ich, dass ich dieses nächste Gerät ausprobieren muss.
Es heißt Heat It und man legt es an die Schuhe.
Wenn man es an die Schuhe legt, legt man es an die Schuhe.
Äh, was?
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wenn ich eine Mücke sticht, wenn ich eine Mücke sticht, dann hältst du das an die Stelle, wo dich die Mücke gestochen hat.
Dann heizt das die Stelle auf und macht dann irgendwie das Gift Zeug kaputt.
Ich hab selbst sowas allerdings nicht fürs Handy.
Ich hab so einen Stift, den benutze ich aber nie.
Okay, warum nicht fürs Handy? Ist eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt.
Alter, okay. 104 Fahrenheit to Celsius.
Moment, hat er 100? Ach, 124. 51 Grad. Okay, 51 Grad. Davon tut es dir ja auch nicht weh.
Das ist doch im Leben nicht Celsius, was der Typ da, was der Typ da sagt, oder?
Degree sagt man zu allem. Das kann auch Degree Fahrenheit sein.
Das ist 124 Fahrenheit.
Okay, dass man kein Kabel legen muss, wird man wireless über einen Laser aufgeladen oder sowas. Eigentlich gar nicht so doof.
Was ist das?
Das ist so eine typische japanische Erfindung irgendwie.
Die mich bei einer Windows-Leiste da unten nervt, Alter.
Ein Mercedes, wie die Amis dazu sagen.
Mercedes.
Okay, RGB-Auto, auf geht's.
Das sollen sie mal dem Lockpickigen Lawyer geben, mal gucken wie lange das durchhält.
Lieber Rewind.
wenn ein Kampf beginnt und dich bewerbt.
Jemand aus ihrem Boot versuchte einen Kampf mit mir zu holen, und er hat es sofort gemerkt.
Dann schaut euch das an, BAM!
Ein anderer Typ hat sich plötzlich übergefallen.
Ich kann mir ein paar NBA-Teams denken, die diesen Typ für ein tolles Floppen machen würden.
Aber die Software kann FALSE auch erkennen, und alles war sehr schnell und akkurat.
Es ist gerade für den Kommerzverbrauch geplant, und es wird bereits in Malls und Sportkomplexen in Japan genutzt.
Es ist garantiert nur über Cloud-AI-Geschiss und dauerhafte Internetverbindungen und Subscription-Plan und alles.
Man darf jetzt nicht denken, man hängt sich einfach die Kamera hin und es funktioniert.
Okay, das ist eine mega coole Idee. Nicht, dass ich mir sowas daheim jemals hinbauen würde,
aber die Idee, die RGB-Strips in so einen Schaum zuzulegen, dass es aussieht wie Wolken, das ist schon echt cool.
Sieht cool aus, ist für daheim halt komplett unsinnig, aber so als Hingucker für die Messe ist es wirklich eine schlaue Idee, was die Marketing-Abteilung da hatte.
Also, die SwitchBot Hub 2, die ein kleines Display hat und ein paar Knöpfe, die du drücken kannst. Die Homey Pro Hub, die dieses Jahr in den USA kommt.
TP-Link hat neue CASA-Switches, die mit Matter funktionieren, und einen Top-O-Matter-Kontroller.
Yeelight hat auch ein paar coole Cube-Lights, die mit Matter funktionieren.
Aber wahrscheinlich die legitimsten aus all diesen Unternehmen, wenn es um Matter geht, ist EVE.
Sie haben seit Jahren Thread-Devices gemacht, und viele von ihnen bekommen ein Firmware-Update, um mit Matter zu arbeiten.
EVE zeigte, wie sie ein Licht kontrollieren können, mit allen Systemen, die mit Matter funktionieren, hier bei CES.
Sie zeigten auch ihre neuen Motion-Blinds.
... die die Existenz der Roller-Blinde schlau machen, indem sie sich auf die Größe verändern.
Es hat eine verbauten Batterie, die ungefähr ein Jahr dauern soll, und es rechargiert mit USB-C.
Sie benutzt Thread, und es funktioniert mit Matter in der Zukunft.
Es ist super, dass er jetzt ein Fernseher steuert.
Kannst du mit Matter zwar theoretisch machen, aber es ist trotzdem besser.
Du hast einen Lichtschalter, da drückst du drauf, der sagt, ich wurde gedrückt, und eine Zentrale steuert dann den Fernseher.
Also und außerdem das alles jemals meta sein wird ist auch unrealistisch
Cs. Wollte bc s without appliances that have ridiculous features that you don't need, but they made them anyways
Samson's, nu das sind Spezialfälle ja aber das smart home besteht dass das smart home für die für die einzelnen für den einzelnen
Ist ja ein großer Spezialfall
Also es geht ja darum dass es einem was bringt und das was mir was bringt ist sicherlich
individuell anders als was es dir bringt
Ich habe auch nicht gesagt dass meta schlecht ist das geht es überhaupt nicht drum am meta wird das grundsätzliche problem
Nicht lösen dass du trotzdem gescheiten hab brauchst und viele verschiedene technologien hast
Es wird trotzdem so sein du wirst guckt du wirst immer noch
eine switchbot app haben du wirst also wenn es denn somit wenn es ohne zentrale macht so ist es switchbot app haben
Du wirst irgendwie die app fürs auto haben du wirst app für dein fernseher haben, app für irgendeine led beleuchtung haben
App für das thermostat haben ja das da wird meta auch nicht großartig was dran ändern
Du kannst vielleicht das einzige was meta wirklich bringen wird ist wenn du so kleinigkeiten machen willst und jetzt sag mal du willst
Mit deinem lichtschalter im flur auch den fernseher an und ausschalten können und beides unterstützt meta
Dass du das irgendwie miteinander perst ohne dass du deine zentrale für brauchst aber
Da sind es wirklich so ganz so ganz kleine sachen wo man sehr schnell rausgewachsen ist und wo auch die handhabung sicherlich nicht schön ist
Inside ist a camera
Das ist richtig es kann Zeitlapsen von deiner kochen und direkt auf die sozialen medien uploaden
Moment moment was so was was bin ich sehend was man nicht braucht aber
Sie haben sie sowieso gemacht samsungs neue bespoke oven hat einen wirklich clean modernen look und
Inside ist eine kamera ein smart ofen das ist richtig es kann Zeitlapsen von deiner kochen und
Upload es direkt auf die sozialen medien
Lasst mich raten lasst mich raten das geht nur per internetanbindung und das samsung cloud dass ich jetzt sagen würde hey
Mach einfach mal einen file share oder so oder irgendwo schiebt man die fotos hin
Dass ich die dann selbst hochladen kann das geht wahrscheinlich nicht
Wahrscheinlich bekommt man diese fotos gar nicht raus außer man postet sie direkt auf instagram
Und wahrscheinlich sobald sich die instagram api ändert und das ding irgendwie keine firmware updates mehr kriegt kann sie die funktion nicht
Mal verwenden das ist alles immer super
kurzfristig und halbherzig implementiert
The influencer camera to get all of those tick-tock views
Samsung also had some updates to their bespoke four-door flex fridge
They increase the screen size to 32 inches and it looks great taking it
Das lag das lag das fucking scroll lag habt ihr es gesehen
Ja looks great almost the entire panel you can also display pictures of your family on it or
pictures, man könnte auch einfach wenn man unbedingt ein bild vorne am
kühlschrank hängen wir haben auch ein bild an kühlschrank hängen oder an dem tablet bild wenn man also
Ist man könnte super viele coole sachen machen mit einem smart kühlschrank ja von automatisch
scannen von codes
Gewichtmessen
So silhouettenerkennung was also man könnte saumäßig richtig vieles cooles zeug machen aber die meisten hersteller zumindest das was ich gesehen habe
Was smarte küchen- und haushaltsgeräte angeht ist wir pappen den bildschirm dran und dann sagen wir es ist smart
Oder wir hängen eine kamera in den in den kühlschrank was du dir auf dem handy angucken kannst und sagen es ist smart
Ne ist es nicht smart wäre wenn das ding zum beispiel feststellen kann ok da wo die milch steht
Das gewicht ist irgendwie geringer jetzt müsste man vielleicht was kaufen dass das dass du
Codes scannen kannst beim in kühlschrank stellen. Du könntest unglaublich viel zeug machen aber vieles davon
ist da
Macht man lieber ein monitor dran und eine kamera rein
Fürs of you and a random guy at c.s. If you want to schenken hat es warum hat das smartphone von dem in knick
Wie soll man das einstecken
Ok das kann man wahrscheinlich gerade machen ja aber es sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aus erst mal
Ja wie ist klar dass man das klappen kann wer bescheuert so ein ding trägt ja sonst keiner rum
Yes, if you want to shake things up and change the color you'll need to use a suction cup to remove the panel
So lg is enter the chat. I've said it in the past that you can't have too much
RGB, but LG is really testing me here
They put RGB light up panels on the front of their fridge
You can change the color sync it to music or have it flash if the door is left open
Just when I an RGB kühlschrank
Da habe ich drauf gewartet
Yes, couldn't announce any more unnecessary products
Mir geht es immer so ich finde diese ganzen sachen auch
wahnsinnig cool
Und manchmal juckt es mir so auch in den fingern zu sagen hey
So was will ich haben aber wisst ihr was mich immer
also was so der
Was so für mich der haken da dran ist an diesem ganzen zeug
Das also ich denke mir immer als erstes ist ja ganz cool und das zweite was ich daran denke ist
Ha wie lang wird das wohl funktionieren?
Weil diese diese ganzen geräte werden werden zum größten teil für den showfaktor
entwickelt und erstellt die hersteller haben da nicht wirklich jetzt in großes interesse dran darauf zu gucken
nehmen wir beispielsweise mal diesen ofen von diesen diesen ofen von samsung
Dieser ofen von samsung der der fotos auf instagram posten kann
Der wird wahrscheinlich nach eins zwei jahren schlichten oder greifend aufhören zu funktionieren
Und du wirst nie wieder irgendwelche updates oder sachen dafür bekommen dass es weitergeht
Der wird wahrscheinlich nach eins zwei jahren einfach auf zu funktionieren aus unterschiedlichsten gründen
Ja der w-land standard ist nicht mehr aktuell genug gut dass nach eins zwei jahren vielleicht ein bisschen
Vielleicht unterstützt es den aktuellsten w-land standard nicht mehr man hat einen neuen router
Vielleicht hat instagram die ap geändert vielleicht gab es paar patches an der was auch immer es kann alle möglichen sachen sein also
Die coolen funktionen werden wahrscheinlich oder noch noch noch viel sind die smartphone app wird nicht mehr aktualisiert
Oder nachdem alles ja mittlerweile da über irgendwelche cloud services geht
Also das problem dass die einfach nach dem
cloud service das geht also das problem dass die einfach nach zwei jahren dann sagen
Ach der cloud service dieses dieses gerät hat sich weltweit eh nur 3000 nachverkauft den cloud service den stellen wir jetzt einfach ein
Oder den cloud service updaten wir nicht mehr und bei der nächsten android version läuft dann die app nicht mehr da sind halt so dinge
Du wirst wahrscheinlich zum größten teil nicht
Jetzt
Lang genug verwenden als dass es sich lohnt also am ende hast du dann halt einen cool aussehenden
modern aussehenden ofen wo die features nicht mehr gehen nach drei vier jahren
Und das ist dann halt ein ganz stink normaler ofen der vielleicht sogar im reinen ofen sein schlechter ist als ein oder 15 ofen
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen was also in meinem auto aktuell also mein mein fiat 500 e
Die kommunikation mit den ganzen ganzen services dort läuft über lte
Sollten die jemals lte abstarten sollten die jemals lte abschalten was wahrscheinlich noch zehn jahre dauern wird ja
Dann kaufe ich mir neues auto aber sollte jemals lte abschalten
Gehen einfach die ganzen services darauf nicht mehr gut ich verwende die e für nix also für mich ist es nicht weiter schlimm
das einzige was ich halt mache ist ich
Im rufe darüber die daten ab für meine heim automatisierung
Also ich rufe da drüber ab
Batteriestand kilometer stand und sowas das wäre natürlich blöd wenn das nicht mehr geht ich meine ich habe ja für homosystem sogar
Für extra extra add-on selbst programmiert
Ja 42 sterne mittlerweile sogar auf github für für das auto sogar ein eigenes homosystem programmiert
Und das geht halt über lte es heißt schalten wir das ab kannst du vergessen
So ein lte modul kann man erneuern ja das wird aber fiat nicht machen
kann es von ausgehen
Also da ist tatsächlich tesla wirklich gut also was die was die elektronik die steuerung und sowas angeht da macht es nach keinem was vor
ist das alles sehr halbherzig was da auch fiat hat aber letztendlich finde ich insofern nicht so schlimm ich verwende eh nichts von dem eingebauten
Funktion das einzige was ich mache ist carplay carplay ans handy und mit dem handy mache ich da navigation und musik und alles möglich also ich verwende quasi nichts
Davon was online services braucht wie gesagt das einzige dass ich halt information in meine heim automatisierung reinkriege
Das wäre halt doof und wirklich wirklich relevant von diesen ganzen informationen ist eigentlich auch nur der kilometer stand und
Die akkuladung der rest ist eigentlich ziemlich spielerei
Es ist halt doof dass du dann im prinzip damit rechnen muss dass die sachen in paian alle nicht mehr funktionieren
Und das ist bei meinem auto mit lte absehbar in maximalen sammeln hat es auch nicht mehr funktioniert
Aber bei diesen geräten und das ist halt das warum ich mir immer denke ah cool aber ich kaufe es mir doch nicht
Der fokus liegt halt einzig und allein auf dem show wert und nach nur nur ganz kurzer zeit
wird das nicht mehr funktionieren und in hersteller wird es nicht jucken
Und selbst wenn es vielleicht nicht bei allen geräten so ist die gefahr ist auf jeden fall da hat man auch oft genug gesehen
und dann kaufe ich mir in dem fall lieber einen ofen der ein richtig guter ofen ist anstatt in ofen mit rgb nur weil es
cool ist wo dann die app nach zweier nicht mal funktioniert dafür
Ich kann ein video über mein auto machen ich muss das nummernschild ab
Abhängen dafür also irgendwas davor hängen vor so man stellt ich muss was vor die fahrer
Zeugnummer hängen weil ich glaube anhand der fahrzeugnummern kriegt man ja auch irgendwelche sachen raus
Ja und dann kann ich euch kann ich mit euch mal ums auto rumlaufen und ins auto reinsetzen viel zu zeigen gibt es ja da eigentlich
gar nicht mal
halt ein auto
elektrisches
Ja kann ich machen es eigentlich habe ich eh schon so viel zu zeigen
Das ist einfach so ein ding weil es geht mich weil es irgendjemand braucht oder
Stell dir mal vor du sitzt im flugzeug und fährst erst mal eine laptop aus
Es ist wirklich ein dual oled screen laptop
Und es ist wirklich ein dual oled screen laptop
cost
8 알아
Um die derivatives hinter eine
Naja
Das kennen wir schon
Kannste deinen Urin analysieren?
Natürlich natürlich selbstverständlich nur über Cloud Service und die offizielle Smartphone App.
Wie kommen wir denn dahin, wenn dieses Teilen die Daten wenigstens normal zur Verfügung stellen würde?
Ich meine ich möchte natürlich mein Vitamingehalt und wie oft ich pissen gehe, am Tag unbedingt in die Cloud zu irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Hersteller hochladen,
anstatt es bei mir selbst im Netzwerk zu halten.
Was sonst? Was sonst?
Yikes, aber will ich Withings auch all diese Daten kennen?
Sie sagen sie können die Unterschiede zwischen den Leuten von ihrem Stream-ID erzählen,
aber das scheint schwierig zu haben, wenn du aufstehen pissen und...
Wenn du es tippen würdest, würde es einfach überall verbreiten? So viele Fragen.
Samsung hat mich mit ein paar Smart-Home-Updaten überrascht.
Eine ist eine neue SmartThings-Station und das ist eine SmartThings-Hub, die Material aus der Box unterstützt.
Aber das, was uns stand-out macht, ist ein wireless Charger...
Ich habe doch ein Video gemacht, da habe ich doch...
SafeSearch ist off, MonkaS.
Ja, ja, ja, SafeSearch muss on hier.
Kack-FPS? Nee, das war ja nicht billig, der Klo.
Und deswegen wäre es halt blöd, wenn man den alle 2-3 Jahre austauschen müsste,
weil die App nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Mein Klo hat halt eine Fernbedienung oder Knöpfe dran.
Und mit den Knöpfen werde ich den auch noch in 5 Jahren bedienen können.
Das einzige, was mein Klo hatte, also wirklich das einzige Service-Problem über die letzten 10 Jahre habe ich den Klo jetzt schon, seit 2013,
über die letzten 10 Jahre war, dass es eine Warnung vom Hersteller gab, Achtung, der Klo könnte Feuer fangen.
Und da dachte ich mir, warum könnte der Klo Feuer fangen?
Weil dort irgendwelches Reinigungsmittel drin war, was...
Da war eine defekte, eine minderwertige Dichtung drin und da konnte dann im Klo das Reinigungsmittel rauslaufen in die Elektronik und theoretisch Feuer fangen.
Das Klo, Leute, ist das in der heutigen Zeit, seid ihr euch da so sicher, dass ihr assumed, was mein Klo wieder sich pronounen will.
Aber bei mir ist es der Klo.
Und da kam dann auch relativ fix ein Hersteller, da kam dann auch relativ fix ein Hersteller und hat das gefixt.
Allerdings erst, jetzt kommt's, der Hersteller hat eine Meldung rausgehauen, Achtung, Klo kann Feuer fangen.
Und wir haben uns dann gemeldet und haben gesagt, hier, wir haben ein Klo, der ist betroffen und es hat Wochen gedauert.
Und sie haben gesagt, dass der einzige Fix dafür ist, man soll die Smartfunktionen vom Klo nicht verwenden, also man soll die Funktionen vom Klo nicht verwenden.
Man soll die normale Spülung verwenden und nicht den Föhn und nicht die Poppelspülung.
Hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich meinen Klo eigentlich nur als normalen Klo verwende, anstatt die Funktionen da drin sind, dass er nicht abfackelt, ist doch irgendwas verkehrt.
So und der Hersteller hat ja gesagt, er behäbt das, aber die haben sich Wochen und Monate nicht gerührt und irgendwann habe ich auf Twitter gepostet.
Irgendwie habe ich auf Twitter, irgendwann habe ich auf Twitter öffentlich gepostet.
Also deswegen ist auch ganz gut, finde ich jetzt nicht, deswegen ist manchmal ganz gut, wenn man viele Follower auf Twitter hat.
Ich habe öffentlich auf Twitter geschrieben, mein Klo kann Feuer, also sinngemäß, mein Klo kann Feuer fangen, aber den Hersteller interessiert es nicht.
Und da hat sich abends um 19 Uhr noch einer aus der Marketing Abteilung von Gamerit gemeldet.
Ich musste einfach nur ein bisschen öffentlich rumflamen auf Twitter und schon funktioniert es.
Rumflamed auf Twitter und schon hatte ich einen Termin, zwei Tage später oder drei Tage später kam dann irgendwie das Servicetechniker und hat das auseinandergeschraubt und hat es ausgebaut und neu eingebaut.
Und seitdem ist alles gut im Klo.
Also sie haben sich ja nicht unbedingt mit Geschwindigkeit, also nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert, was die Geschwindigkeit angeht.
Da kannst du ja nicht sagen, Leute, euer Premium Klo, das kannst du nicht mehr benutzen, weil sonst eure Wohnung abfackelt, aber wir kümmern uns da Wochen und Monate nicht rum.
Was ist da los?
Der Typ war wirklich gut, also da hast du gemerkt, der weiß, was er macht.
Er hat das zackig auseinandergebaut, sauber gemacht, wieder eingebaut.
Dann hat er noch den Schlauch von der Spülung irgendwie gefixt nebenbei und alles hat Gamerit bezahlt.
Also am Ende kann ich mich überhaupt nicht drüber beschweren, war, glaube ich, der fähigste Klempner und so, den ich je da hatte.
Aber es hat wirklich zu lange gedauert zwischen Achtung, dein Klo kann brennen und bis einer kam.
Und es kam ja auch nur einer, weil ich öffentlich mit irgendwie 20k plus Followern rumgeflammt habe.
Inline Skates auf dem Teppich, Alter!
Was?
Okay.
Klingt erstmal irgendwie cool, aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin früher saumäßig viel Inline Skates gefahren, aber seit ein paar Jahren, seit ein paar Jahren weniger.
Die hatten auch nicht nur drei Rollen, die hatten auch, die hatten auch mehr Rollen.
Aber mit einem Motor erschließt sich das mehr gar nicht, weil das war ein bisschen Bewegung.
Das war ein bisschen Bewegung. Ich meine, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen wie bei einem Fahrrad, dass es dich zusätzlich unterstützt.
Was?
Okay, was kostet das 2 Millionen?
Wie? Nur 390.000 Dollar?
Auf geht's!
Das ist beeindruckend!
Auf geht sowas.
Das ist der Typ, der 35 Smart Home Apps installiert hat, genau.
Übrigens, das Display ist richtig, richtig schlecht.
Guck mal, das ist so ein ganz, so ein ganz billiges Ding, wie ich teilweise schon irgendwelche ESPs angeschlossen habe.
Ja, das kann jetzt das Wasser, das kann jetzt das Wasser, den Schwamm irgendwie reinigen vom Ding.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich bin, den Mob würde ich eh nicht verwenden.
Ich hatte ja auch mal einen Roborock mit Mob-Funktion, ich hab den nie moppen lassen.
Ich hab den nur saugen lassen, aber ich hab auch keinen gehabt mit Absaugestation.
Und das war für mich tatsächlich so, wie sagt man so schön heutzutage, der Dealbreaker.
Mir war es zu nervig, diesen Container immer rein und raus zu machen vom Roboter.
Hätte ich jetzt eine Absaugestation und müsste da einmal die Woche oder einmal im Monat oder alle 14 Tage, was auch immer, den Mülleimer leeren,
dann könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, wieder einen Staubsauger-Roboter zu benutzen.
Ich saug einfach normal jetzt.
Das einzige, wo du hier im Haus putzen müsstest, ist hier oben im ersten Stock gar nicht, außer im Bad.
Das ist alles Teppich und ansonsten unten ist es Bad, Flur und theoretisch Küche.
Aber da ist das hartes Ding ja eh nicht geputzt, das hat er eh nur oben geputzt.
Auf den neuen Roborocks läuft er tatsächlich auch mittlerweile, weil er Tudor.
Allerdings hast du das Problem, du musst ihn dafür auseinander bauen und da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Teppich muss man saugen, es ging nicht um saugen, es ging ums Putzen. Mit Lappen.
Wenn du den mit Kassemfirma flaschen willst, musst du ihn auseinander bauen, dass du an die Pins kommst.
Also ganz ehrlich Wasser reicht mir.
Alles klar, jetzt müssen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt müssen wir Bescheid, dass wieder ziemlich viel Zeug dabei ist, was cool ist, aber ich mir nicht kaufen werde.
Echt, war das so teuer?
Ich hab den Preis jetzt gar nicht mitbekommen, scheint mir jetzt aber ein bisschen zu teuer.
Aber nur gerade, ich glaub ganz so teuer wird das nicht sein. Nix großartiges dabei, das eine ist halt so ein viergiges Keramikding.
CES haben wir jetzt schon geguckt.
Was soll das sein? Irgendein Knopf, der einen Windows Mixer bedient oder was? Im Schnelldurchlauf, diese Videos sind meistens jebait.
Außer unter Windows 11.
Sieht irgendwie ein bisschen billig aus oder?
Naja, okay, es ist im Prinzip der Windows Mixer, weil solange das nicht unterschiedliche Inputs hat und sich als unterschiedliche Soundkarten anmeldet und das irgendwie mixen kann, ist das ja eine reine Softwarelösung mit quasi Integration in den Windows Mixer.
Zeig das mal von hinten.
Ja, zeig mal von hinten.
Nein, da schließt du nix an hinten dran, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein... im Prinzip steuert das dein Windows Mixer.
Ja, ja, hast den gar Anschluss.
Ey, ja, Windows Mixer. Es steuert im Prinzip den Windows Mixer.
Ja, man kann auch einfach in den Windows Mixer klicken und das einstellen. Oh nein! Oh!
Das ist ja undenkbar. Ich muss in den Windows Mixer und ein paar Slidern hoch und runter mit der Maus machen. Da greife ich lieber an den Knopf und drehe rum.
Okay, ich muss sagen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen was Sinnvolles hattest. Also gerade, ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du, wenn du wirklich streamt,
und ab und zu vielleicht mal Discord an und aus und so, okay, es könnte durchaus was Sinnvolles haben.
Also wobei ich das, by the way, nicht brauche. Ich habe hier mein Audiointerface und da habe ich auch einen Knopf dran.
Da kann ich einfach, kann ich auswählen, welchen Input-Channel und kann es lauter und leiser machen.
Das ist einfach, das ist einfach, das ist einfach, das ist einfach, das ist einfach, das ist einfach, das ist einfach.
Also wobei ich das, by the way, nicht brauche. Ich habe hier mein Audiointerface und da habe ich auch einen Knopf dran. Da kann ich einfach, kann ich auswählen, welchen Input-Channel und kann es lauter und leiser machen. Das ist auch kein Ding.
Ja, sowas könnte man super easy selbst machen, tatsächlich. Aber da wäre ich zu faul für. Du brauchst ein Gehäuse, dann brauchst du die Knöpfe. Knöpfe habe ich sogar, sogar da.
Du brauchst im Endeffekt nur den ESP32, schließt vier Knöpfe an, brauchst halt ein ordentliches Gehäuse, was wahrscheinlich am schwierigsten wird.
Machst ein ordentliches Gehäuse und dann musst du halt irgendwie gucken, dass es vom ESP32 an Windows-Software rankommt.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile sogar ESP32, die sich per USB anmelden können. Doch, doch, gibt es. Es gibt glaube ich mittlerweile ESP32, wo es sogar USB-Dinger gibt.
Und im ESP32 brauchst du nicht mal, genau, nicht mal USB, da könntest du sogar Wireless machen. Musst halt irgendwie. Ja, ja, ist okay. Ist aber, ist aber. Also ich verstehe den Komfort in der Arbeit, die Leute. Ja.
Okay, also sieben Minuten damit zu füllen ist auch erstmal nicht ohne. Ah ja, okay, ich verstehe, ich verstehe den Vorteil schon.
Okay. Was haben wir hier? Eleven Shell-Aliases you'll use today. Ach ja, ist auch so. Okay, wir skippen, wir skippen mal schnell drüber. Also, was?
Leute, wir wissen alle, dass es Shit heißt und ich geht. Managing JSON, okay. Copy Paste und JSON Pretty Print, alles klar. Gut, next please.
Creating Directories, okay. Der legt ein Directory an und switcht direkt rein. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, ist ganz nützlich, alles klar.
Displace ist eine Mac-Geschichte. Dafür brauche ich doch kein Alias. Docker aufräumen, okay, klingt halbwegs sinnvoll. Trimming Strings brauche ich nicht im Terminal.
Notizen habe ich was anderes für. Da habe ich selbst tatsächlich Alias für. Static Files. Das Alias ist sinnvoll, sowas in der Richtung habe ich auch. Trash habe ich auch. Okay, nice, easy.
Alles klar, Video durch. Video komprimiert in 20 Sekunden. Speedrunning Video.
Almost spectacular. Da bin ich aber überlegen, mir das Teil zu holen. Sind Microsurfaces überbewert, das mir jetzt zu harte kostet. Bin ich zu dumm zum Programmieren?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, wir sind alle viel zu dumm. Wir machen es aber trotzdem, das ist halt das Problem da dran. Eigentlich sind, außer der Twitch Chat, Twitch Chat ist zu high IQ für alles.
Also man könnte es zusammenfassen mit, ja wir sind zu dumm, aber wir machen es trotzdem. Kann sein, denn Fakt ist, nicht jeder ist fürs Programmieren gemacht.
Das stimmt. Bevor du diesem Video deinen Dislike gibst. Es ist tatsächlich nicht jeder für alles gemacht. Deswegen ist es ja auch immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig, wenn sie so tun, als könntest du jeden irgendwie zu IT-Leuten umschulen.
Du kannst nicht den ehemaligen Kohle-Bergbauarbeiter nehmen und davon jeden zum Anwendungsentwickler umschulen. Die haben da vielleicht einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht das Händchen für.
Ein paar sicherlich, aber in der großen Masse wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so sein. Da muss da schon einen gewissen eigenen Antrieb und Hang dazu haben.
Grand-Kommentar schreibst und in ein anderes Video klickst. Lass mich erklären. Es gibt viele Dinge, die scheinbar ziemlich wichtig sind, wenn man Programmieren lernen will.
Da gibt es viele Fragen, die man sich stellt. Muss ich gut in Mathe sein? Muss ich gut in der Schule sein?
Kommt drauf an, was man programmieren will. In der Schule muss man nicht gut sein. Brauche ich Abitur oder sogar ein Studium? Oder muss man generell besonders intelligent sein?
Ich würde sagen, in diesem Video schauen wir zu... Wir fragen mal genauer an und finden heraus, ob man wirklich zu dumm sein kann. Aber jetzt erstmal die Frage...
Oh ja, man kann definitiv zu dumm sein.
...ob sich das...
Taut mir Leute, das geht, das geht. Man kann definitiv zu dumm sein.
...nach dir anhört. Als du das erste Mal programmiert hast, hattest du keine Ahnung, was du da überhaupt machst. Du warst überfordert und frustriert und sowas kann ziemlich an die Substanz gehen.
Aber irgendwie hat es dir trotzdem Spaß gemacht. Irgendetwas hat dich daran fasziniert, als du das erste Mal Hello World ausgegeben hast. Und trotzdem hat es nie so richtig geklingelt.
Ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht sicher, ob ich jemals zum Einstieg sowas wie Hello World... Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das... Hab ich nie...
Ich glaube, das war definitiv... Also es war auf jeden Fall nicht meine erste Zeile.
Und klar, stellst du dir dann die Frage, bin ich vielleicht einfach zu dumm für das Ganze? Nehmen wir mal diese Grafik mit Kompetenz...
Also ich würde mal sagen, die meisten Leute sind nicht zu dumm. Leute, die sich für IT und... Also Leute, die auf die Idee kommen, selbstständig, dass sie programmieren lernen wollen, die sind nicht zu doof.
Also wenn du schon auf die Idee kommst, das machen zu wollen, dich, dass sich das interessiert, dann bist du nicht zu doof.
Aber es gibt insgesamt definitiv Leute, die wären zu doof. Die haben dann aber wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Hang dazu und gar kein Interesse daran.
Kompetenz und Selbstbewusstsein. Nach den ersten Programmiereinheiten und den ersten kleineren Erfolgen steigt die Kompetenz ein wenig, aber das Selbstbewusstsein steigt unverhältnismäßig an.
Doch genau hier oben befindest du dich und hast jetzt ein Problem. Du merkst, dass es immer mehr zu lernen gibt und die Themen werden noch irgendwie immer komplexer.
Bist du also schlau genug, um hier weiterzumachen? Es gibt viele Gründe, wieso man beim Programmieren an sich selbst zweifelt.
Vielleicht war man nie besonders gut in der Schule, hat ein schlechtes Abitur oder die Schule gar nicht erst beendet.
Programmieren lernen bedeutet, dass man sich permanent mit komplexen Problemen und Konzepten befasst und das Woche für Woche, Tag für Tag.
In der Schule lernt man in der Regel überhaupt nicht, wie man programmiert, weshalb viele erst im Studium das erste Mal damit in Berührung kommen.
Programmieren, dass mehr als nur ein paar Zeilen kommen.
Wie man programmiert ist ganz einfach. Du gibst ein How-to-blablabla-stack-overflow und dann guckst du dir, was möglichst viele Upvotes hat und das, was die meisten Upvotes hat, copypastest du und sagst, das ist jetzt fertig.
Aber in meiner langjährigen Berufserfahrung habe ich mit unzähligen sehr, sehr guten Entwicklern zusammengearbeitet, die teilweise auch... Und heute kannst du Chat-GPD fragen.
Was ist, wenn ich da sage, dass mein Abi-Schnitt auch nicht im Einserbereich lag?
Leute, mein Abi-Schnitt lag auch nicht im Einserbereich.
Ich hatte einen Abschluss von 2,8 und ich war richtig stolz drauf, aber wenigstens sollte man doch in Mathe ziemlich was auf dem Kasten haben.
Nichts war insläufig. Es kommt drauf an. Es kommt drauf an, was man so programmiert.
Man muss viel mit Zahlen und Berechnungen umgehen.
Die Algorithmen, die man programmiert, sind im Prinzip wie die Formeln, die du aus dem Mathematikunterricht kennst.
Aber wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind, je nachdem, in welcher Branche du arbeitest, brauchst du überhaupt gar keine Mathematik.
Naja, abgesehen von den Grundrechenoperationen wie Plus, Minus, Mal, geteilt. Die sollte man schon einigermaßen verstanden haben.
Und selbst wenn du ein Videospiel programmieren möchtest, dann werden auch dort die komplexen Algorithmen und Berechnungen direkt von der Game Engine übernommen.
Du musst dich also auch dort nicht sonderlich damit beschäftigen.
Auch wenn es nicht immer einfach ist, sich bestimmte Themen in der Programmierung anzueignen, ist für viele ein Grund, sich dennoch damit zu beschäftigen, das mögliche Gehalt.
Denn Einstiegsgehälter von 50.000 Euro brutto im Jahr sind durchaus realistisch.
Und damit du jetzt nicht denkst, dass ich mir die Zahlen einfach random aus den Fingern sauge, schauen wir doch gemeinsam mal in den neuesten Tech Salary Report von TalentIO rein.
Ist das Sponsored? Bye!
Dieses Video hier Sponsored.
Ich hab's schon gedacht. Ich hab's mir schon gedacht.
Dort wurden Zahlen von 100.000 Jobangeboten gesammelt und ausgewertet.
Alles um die Frage zu beantworten, welches Gehalt du tatsächlich erwarten kannst.
Und nicht nur als Softwareentwickler, sondern auch als Data Scientist.
Wir machen mal jetzt, wir erfreuen die jetzt mal.
Talent.io
Ja, Tech Shop Unisurf, Lead Developer für 70.000 Euro.
Als Lead Developer, ah gut Berlin, Berlin ist ja eh so ein Shit Show Ding.
Da hast du wahrscheinlich auch nicht so die krassesten Gelder.
Weil ich eigentlich erwarten würde, dass es sowohl in, also in Frankfurt weiß ich es halt und ich würde eigentlich auch erwarten, dass es in anderen größeren Städten, also in Köln beispielsweise,
ist ja auch IT-mäßig recht viel am Start und dass es auch in Berlin ordentlich was gibt.
So, was kann man jetzt hier machen auf der Seite?
Erstmal muss ich mich sign innen.
Okay, find your next job.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht das hier.
Dark Reader machen wir mal aus.
Find, okay, Moment, ich muss Dark wieder ran.
Starting by creating an account.
Okay, ah ja.
Okay, copy, Passport, zack, next.
It's great to meet you.
First, first name, Peter, A, G, French, E.
Wie macht man das?
Okay.
What type of contract are you looking for?
When are you available to start?
Mal was realistisches mal.
Komm, hier haben wir irgendwie, da ist da mehr zu.
Next.
Overall years of experience in tech.
15.
Machen wir einfach mal 15.
Development infrastructure security testing.
Full stack developer, backend developer.
Frontend developer haben wir bloß auf.
DevOps engineer, System administrator, Network.
Machen wir mal so.
Komm, wir machen mal, wir machen mal was anderes.
Wir machen mal wirklich nur die zwei Sachen hier.
Senior, senior, next.
Technologies.
Kann man da, kann man da irgendwas ein?
Kubernetes zum Beispiel, ah ja, Kubernetes.
Linux.
Wo ist die, Leute, Skills, wo ist meine Skill-Liste?
Wo habe ich die?
Wo habe ich hier Skills?
Skills.
Da.
Nein, Edge, Edge, geh weg.
Edge.
Nerv mich jetzt nicht.
Also.
Git, Git-Muster, shit, shit-Muster rein.
Git.
Gibt es da gar nicht, haha.
Okay, nee, okay, da müssen wir jetzt irgendwas finden,
was da aus der halbwegs passt.
Also.
SSL, Encrypt.
Was machen wir denn hier?
Edge, Container.
Scheiße, was gibt, gibt es überhaupt hier irgendwas von?
Terraform.
Ansible.
Okay.
Einfach so.
Füllen wir das einfach mal noch anders, anders aus.
Was könnte denn da noch drinne?
Zabbix.
Prometheus, nee.
Grafana, nee.
Ach du Scheiße, man.
Mir fällt jetzt da nichts anderes mehr ein, gibt es da nichts von?
Okay, was gibt es denn da so?
Lass mal hier durchscrollen.
ASP.NET, ja, warum nicht?
Bash, oh ja, Bash, Bash will ich unbedingt machen.
Chef.
Was ist Trollz?
Trollz.
Elastica, Embedded Linux,
Ember.js.
Eats, die Eats-Plattform.
Go,
GraphQL, Groovy.
Hyper-V,
MonkaS.
Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach checken,
wir brauchen einfach, oh nee, es fängt wieder von vorne an.
Das UI ist jetzt nicht so geil hier von der Seite.
Linux.
Und, meine Güte.
Spotnet kann man auch reinmachen.
Ubiquite.
Ubi, Ruby.
Spring SQL...
Was ist denn Storm Shield?
Unity.
Windows,
nee, wenn eine Sache, dann nicht Windows.
Okay, was machen wir, als Fünftes reinkommt,
Terraform noch und Next.
Import? Nein, nein, nein, ich will kein LinkedIn-Profil importieren.
Next. Country of Residence, Germany. 6032... 60329. 100% remote.
Ach komm, wir machen mal beides. Any Country. Nein, Frankfurt. Frankfurt. Weder Berlin, noch Hamburg, noch München. Frankfurt.
Okay, dann machen wir einfach nur 100% remote. We are all sitting in one boat.
Na ja, da muss schon, da muss schon was, da muss schon was hinkommen, die rumkommen.
Okay, dann machen wir es nicht. Dann lassen wir es dann einfach bleiben.
Wo waren wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben? Ja, bin ich zu dumm zum Programmieren.
Produktmanager oder Führungspositionen wie beispielsweise als CTO. Wir finden hier Daten zu verschiedenen Ländern, aber wir schauen uns natürlich Deutschland an.
Direkt wichtig anzumerken ist, dass die Zahlen keine Durchschnittswerte, sondern der Median ist.
Das ist wichtig, weil sonst Ausreißer, die besonders viel oder besonders wenig verdienen, das Ergebnis verfälschen.
Die wichtigsten Städte in Deutschland für ITler sind natürlich Hamburg, Berlin und München.
Und wenn wir genau hinschauen, dann sehen wir, dass die Unter...
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, persönlich so unwichtig ist Frankfurt auch nicht.
...dass die Unterschiede wirklich minimal sind. Im Median verdienen Entwickler überall circa 60.000 Euro brutto im Jahr.
Da nicht jeder Entwickler dasselbe macht, kann man hier mal verschiedene Bereiche miteinander vergleichen.
Beispielsweise Frontend, Backend, Fullstech und auch die...
Okay, die verdienen ungefähr das gleiche, alle.
Die verdienen auch überall fast das gleiche, ja.
Lead, Lead...
Ein Lead, Fullstech oder wie?
Na ja, gut.
Siehst du mal, schon weitere Vorteile in Frankfurt zu arbeiten, gibt's mehr Kohle.
Den Report findest du kostenlos bei talent.io. Melde dich einfach beim Talent Club an und du bekommst zum einen natürlich Zugang zum Tech Salary Report
und zusätzlich noch alle zwei Wochen einen Newsletter mit wichtigen Insights für deinen Start in die Tech-Industrie.
Ja, hab ich grad probiert, die wollten meine Handynummer, da wollte ich nicht mehr.
Den Link dazu findest du natürlich unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber ein Studium sollte man trotzdem haben, oder?
Denn wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, wie soll man überhaupt Programmieren lernen können, wenn man nicht mal Informatik studiert hat?
Und für so ein Studium muss man ja bekanntlich ein Überbrain sein.
Und dazu kann ich dir genau zwei Dinge sagen.
Nummer eins, im Studium hatte ich Informatik-Kollegen, die nicht unbedingt begabter waren, als ich es war.
Natürlich war es einschüchtern, als diese mit ihren Schlagwörtern um sich gehauen haben, aber ganz ehrlich unter uns, da darf man sich nicht einschüchtern lassen.
Und zweitens, ich habe auch keine reine Informatik studiert.
Die meisten meiner Arbeitskollegen haben auch nicht die reine Informatik, sondern irgendeine...
Ja, die meisten studieren Wirtschaftsinformatik, weil sie sich denken, da ist Mathe nicht so schwierig.
Etwas anderes studiert. Sie kamen also auch nicht von der Universität als perfekt ausgebildete Software-Entwickler.
Aber als Programmierer sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mit allen möglichen Technologien auseinandersetzen.
Stimmt.
Egal, ob man eine App für das Smartphone, eine Website für einen Blog oder eben ein Videospiel entwickeln muss.
Immerhin ist man ja IT-Spezialist und sollte in der Lage sein, jedes technische Problem zu lösen.
Naja, jedes sicherlich auch nicht.
Aber ein bisschen sich damit zu beschäftigen, ist nicht verkehrt.
Ganz im Ernst, okay, mobile habe ich jetzt auch nicht so den Durchblick.
Aber ich bin zum Beispiel seit den letzten paar Jahren schon der Meinung, es kommt keiner mehr so wirklich an Frontend-Technologie vorbei.
Also ein bisschen HTML, JavaScript, CSS sollte jeder Ahnung von haben, selbst wenn er Cobalt-Backend-Entwickler ist.
Das schadet nicht.
Und sich auch mit aktuellen Technologien, sei es Cloud, sei es Provisioning und auch mit den Plattformen, wo die Software dann im Endeffekt drauf läuft,
dass man sich mal ein bisschen Linux anguckt, sowas, das sorgt unter dem Strich dafür, dass man ein besserer Entwickler ist.
Klar, du kannst natürlich auch total Tunnelblick machen und ich mache genau eine Sprache und genau ein Framework, wofür ich bezahlt werde.
Und für alles Neue will ich nicht oder brauche erst mal ein halbes Jahr Einarbeitungszeit.
Aber die wirklich guten Leute, die ich kenne, die interessieren sich von sich aus getrieben schon für neue Sachen.
Entwickler spezialisieren sich auf einen bestimmten Bereich und oftmals arbeiten sie mit nur einer oder vielleicht zwei Programmiersprachen bei ihrer täglichen Arbeit.
Das stimmt wohl, aber das heißt nicht, dass man sich in die anderen Sachen nicht auch angucken sollte.
Also ich habe auch mittlerweile festgestellt, am liebsten mache ich Sachen in C-Sharp, das ist einfach die Sprache, die mir am besten gefällt.
Aber ich habe auch schon Sachen in Go gemacht, wir haben auch schon Sachen in JavaScript gemacht, wir haben auch schon Sachen in C++ gemacht,
also sogar schon kleine Sachen in Rust gemacht und auch ganz kleine Sachen in Kobol gemacht.
Und wer sagt, das stimmt nicht, kann sie im Stream Archive angucken.
Aber trotzdem, wenn man sich nur eine Sache anguckt, weiß man ja gar nicht, was man vielleicht verpasst.
Arbeit. Es ist also nicht sinnvoll, sich zu Beginn mit vielen verschiedenen Programmiersprachen und Technologien gleichzeitig zu verabschieden,
sondern suche dir eine Technologie oder Programmiersprache aus und versuche die richtig gut zu bewerben.
Das stimmt, da würde ich ihm recht geben. Aber trotzdem, insgesamt sollte man schon ein bisschen rumgucken.
Ich bin der Meinung, die meisten Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, was sie jetzt konkret machen wollen,
sollen sich einfach einen Texteditor schnappen und ein bisschen JavaScript basteln.
Du brauchst nichts dafür, die Einstiegshürde für JavaScript ist die kleinste, die es gibt.
Du brauchst einen Texteditor und du brauchst einen Webbrowser.
Das Problem bei JavaScript fängt danach an, dass das JavaScript Ökosystem total unübersichtlich und wirr ist.
Aber mittlerweile haben sich die letzten Jahre über ja schon so ein paar Sachen rauskristallisiert.
99% der Leute verwenden Node.js und nicht Deno und auch nicht Bunn und hast du nicht gesehen.
Node.js dementsprechend installieren die Leute über NPM oder PNPM ihre Packages und da kommt man schon halbwegs hin.
Denn trotzdem ist das JavaScript Ökosystem etwas unübersichtlich.
Gerade zu Beginn wird man mit verschiedenen Konzepten und Schlagwörtern überhäuft.
Man liest von APIs, Speichermanagement, Garbage Collection, Webrequests, Callbacks, Funktionen, Variablen, Klassen und Optimierung.
Diese Dinge muss man auch nicht von Anfang an richtig verstehen, weil sonst ist man einfach nicht fürs Programmieren gemacht.
Also suche dir vielleicht doch etwas anderes. Falsch, denn jedes Konzept ist nur ein Puzzleteil im Großen Ganzen.
Manche Dinge versteht man schneller und bei anderen braucht man Monate, bis man nur ansatzweise verstanden hat.
Oder es gibt Sachen wie C++, die versteht man nie.
Überhaupt passiert. Ich beispielsweise habe mir in den ersten zwei Jahren die Programmierung der iOS-Entwicklung selbst beigebracht.
Denkst du, ich habe dabei direkt verstanden, was Automatic Reference Counting ist?
Ja, das kann man aber auch sofort verstehen, wenn man sich damit schon mal auseinandergesetzt hat in einem anderen Kontext.
Das ist ja jetzt nichts iOS-spezifisches Automatic Reference Counting.
In Rust gibt es das auch. Da wird das zum Beispiel mit ARK abgekürzt.
Weil nur dann ist es Blazingly Fast in Rust und die ganzen Crustaceans freuen sich.
Rust ist schon ein bisschen Cringe, oder?
FFmpeg macht das übrigens auch für Buffer. Sobald du nicht mehr brauchst, werden sie aufgeräumt.
Leute, ich wusste in der ersten Zeit nicht mal, dass es so etwas gibt.
Aber wenn man am Ball bleibt, sich für das Thema interessiert, dann hat man auch die Muße, sich durchzubeißen.
Auch jetzt, nach fast zehn Jahren in der iOS-Entwicklung, lerne ich noch regelmäßig neue Konzepte.
Nee, du hast recht, in Rust ist es Atomic Reference Counter.
Ah, das ist das, aus mehreren Threads drauf zu...
Siehste? Okay, dann habe ich Mist erzählt, dann ist es doch was anderes.
Also ist Automatic Reference Counter wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sowas, was ein Garbage-Collector macht.
Gucken, ob es Referenzen gibt auf irgendein Objekt oder auf irgendeine Variable und es dann automatisch aufräumen.
Okay, da müsste man tatsächlich mal gucken. Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das in den ersten Monaten oder Jahren verstanden haben.
Es gibt das berühmte Zitat, je mehr ich weiß, umso mehr weiß ich, dass ich nichts weiß.
Und das ist wirklich super passend.
Das ist ja das, das hat das Sokrates nicht angeblich gesagt und mittlerweile ist man sich relativ sicher, dass er das gar nicht gesagt hätte.
Du bist also nicht verrückt, wenn du zu Beginn nicht alles verstehst, denn in diesem Kaninchenbau willst du dich nicht verehren.
Du wirst sehen, wieso du in manchen Themen so superschnell alles durchblickst und bei anderen gefühlt nie das Ende des Tunnels erblickst.
Beim Programmieren ist die Syntax, also die Grammatikregeln, die man in einer Programmiersprache befolgen muss, ziemlich schnell schlüssig.
Aber Dinge wie Frameworks, sauberen Code, kleinere Feinheiten in der Programmiersprache benötigen viel.
Ja, Testing. Testing ist eh overrated. Wer keine Fehler programmiert, muss auch nicht testen.
In der Zeit und Energie, damit du sie verstanden hast. Und das darfst du nicht vergessen.
Was will ich eigentlich damit sagen? Selbstzweifel sind völlig normal und nein, du bist nicht zu dumm zum Programmieren.
Wer testen hat Angst, genau.
Jeder hat gleich viel Talente.
Und wer kommentiert, kann einfach selbsterklärenden Code programmieren.
Es ist auch normal, dass man nicht nach ein paar Tagen Code und Kontrolle von Programmiern profiliert.
Es ist nun mal ein Handwerk und das benötigt viel Zeit und Energie, um es richtig zu beherrschen.
Du befindest dich gerade hier oben. Der Klickmoment wird garantiert irgendwann mal kommen.
Du musst nur das richtige Projekt finden, in das du bereit bist, deine Mühe zu stecken.
Ich kann dir an dieser Stelle übrigens ans Herz legen, dass du auf meinen Discord-Server kommst.
Denn dort wirst du auch relativ schnell merken, dass du absolut nicht alleine bist.
Na ja.
Ihr könnt auch bei mir auf den Discord-Server kommen.
Wir haben auch ein Programmiere-Hilfe-Sub-Discord-Channel-Ding.
Dann hoffe ich, dass es dir gefallen hat.
Das ist sogar relativ aktiv.
Abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Da gibt es täglich, immer wenn ich das aufmache nachmittags, schon wieder alles vollgespammt.
Noch nichts gemacht hast und ich hoffe, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Dein Kevin.
Du wurdest gebannt?
Moment, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ach du warst das, der sich angemeldet hat mit 13 oder so?
Ja gut, das habe ich nur am Rande mitgekriegt, dass man, dass man, was auch immer.
Wir haben letztens einen bannen müssen.
Ich habe das, wie gesagt, ich bin ja da selbst nicht so wirklich dran beteiligt.
Ich lese natürlich aber immer, was so im Discord moderationstechnisch passiert.
Es musste letztens einer gebannt werden, weil er irgendwelche Domains mit Hitler und so drinnen gepostet hat.
Wo ich mir auch denke, was zum Teufel ist mit den Leuten los?
Warum macht man sich solche Domains, Alter?
Das ist ja PainsChamber, weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Aus ist 12.
Leute, wisst ihr, was das heißt?
Was, was, was könnte, was könnte das bedeuten?
Da kriege ich immer Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute, ich habe Hunger.
12 verschiedene Gerichte.
Nee, ich esse Nudeln von gestern.
Nudelors.
Jetzt was gucken.
Okay, alles klar Leute, ich gehe fordern.
Wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream, bis dann.
See you.